we keep a moment of remembrance and
respect
honoring sir david amis
the honorable member for south and west
colleague and friend
may the bright memory of his rich life
ever outshine
the tragic manner of his death
let us keep silence
thank you
i'm sorry the house is returning in such
tragic circumstances
since we last met we have lost two
outstanding friends and colleagues sir
david amos and james brokenshire
i know honourable and writer and will
members from all parts of this house
will share my deep sadness at their loss
and will want to join me in senegal
heartfelt condolences to their families
the circumstances of sir david's death
were despicable
and the rays of the most fundamental
issues about how members of this house
are able to perform our vital democratic
responsibilities safely and securely
in light of the ongoing police
investigation i will not say more about
the events but i give the house my
undertaking that i will do everything
within my power to ensure that these
issues are treated with urgency and with
the sense of priority that they deserve
i know that whatever political
differences that there are in the house
all members want to ensure
not just that we and our staff are able
to work safely but there were democracy
itself with local member of parliament
at the heart of our constituency is able
to function securely
on that i know the house is united
the house will want to pay tribute to
both sir david and to james and i hope
it will be useful if i set out how i
expect us to be able to do so
on wednesday after prime minister's
questions there will be an opportunity
for tributes to be paid to james
brokenshire
today's planned substantive business in
the chamber in the westminster hall will
not be proceeded with instead
we will have home office questions
followed by an opportunity to pay
tribute to sir david amis on a motion
for the german to be opened by the prime
minister
at 6 00 pm there will be a service of
primary members to commemorate sir david
at saint margaret's church
i expect the house to adjourn
approximately at 5 30 p.m for those
members who wish to attend the service
then to proceed from this chamber to
saint margaret's
i know many many members want to speak
and if we can bear that in mind it will
help us all that we get it on the record
and just to say there will be books of
condolence members to sign along with
staff as well
so please let us now move to questions
to home secretary
and now
we now come to cheryl murray
one please mr speaker
i'm secretary thank you mr speaker
before i come on to my response i will
pay my tribute shortly to our dear
friend sir david but i want to echo your
words and start by saying that his
killing is a terrible and sad moment
in our history an attack on our
democracy and an appalling tragedy and
we are all thinking of david julia and
their family and i would mr speaker like
to echo your words about our dear dear
colleague james brokenshire the member
of palm frog bexley and syd cup
who bravely battled cancer over the last
year and james cathy and their children
are absolutely in all our thoughts
in response to question number one mr
speaker
these protests
are extremely dangerous they have caused
great economic harm they've called
misery and distress of the law abide in
public and they've also prevented
members of the public from going about
their daily business
thank you mr speaker on friday we saw
the worst type of illegal protest where
my good friend was stabbed as he did his
job mr speaker i hope to catch your eye
later and give my own tribute to this
most excellent fellow and i thank you
for making this possible
i know sadly on this occasion it was one
of our colleagues but will the
government review how we help to keep
those safe
all of those people who work in public
facing roles
my honorable friend
i echo the words of mumble friend
actually in terms of her remarks and the
points that she has made and of course
we have a duty and a responsibility and
there is a great deal of work taking
place right now with mr speaker with our
police force across the country police
forces across the country to do exactly
that and there'll be further
updates over the next few days
particularly for members of parliament
but also in terms of wider public
protection
well chris brown
thank you mr speaker i of course too
also pay tribute to sir david amis i
never managed to persuade him to support
gay marriage
but
he always asked after my husband and i
think that that was the character of the
man
the difficulty is judging what the
boundary is between
legal and illegal protests because some
people protesting
online
use vile abuse they think that that's
perfectly justifiable we seem to have
developed a toxic way of doing our
politics
how do we simply change that so that
we've become
a bit more like
sir david and for that matter a bit more
like james
well my russian friend actually
raises
i think actually something that has just
been captured actually by the mood of
the nation around the discourse that we
have in public life now clearly the
online space we see far too much cruelty
online and i think all of us have a
responsibility and a duty to work
together and i do think working together
is part of the solution here
and then of course when it comes to this
place and to public life and politics i
would use one word and that is respect
julian
number two mr speaker
mr speaker can i start by associating
myself with the remarks of the home
secretary uh with regard to james broken
show who i worked with over the last 15
years on all manner of subjects he was a
lovely man and a pleasure to
to know uh it's also a poignant moment
as i group this question with question
five to realize that he would have
spotted so david would have spotted the
subject of this these two questions and
given his long interest in animal
welfare
should in any just world be bobbing
behind us now to ask a question
mr speaker stealing up from a pet from
its loving owner is a particularly cruel
crime causing heartbreak for families in
great distress to the pet the home
office is working with the police to
ensure pet deaths are recorded in a
consistent manner and readily
identifiable within forces information
management systems across england and
wales the pet theft task force has
recently made a series of
recommendations which we're considering
and we will introduce a new criminal
offence for pet abduction
as well wasn't it
thank you mr speaker can i start by
adding my tribute to sir david
he was dedicated as the minister said to
dedicated his career for better animal
welfare and i know that this topic was
one that was very close to his heart and
he had been lobbying the minister very
hard on
um
mr speaker as we continue to see the
rise in pet theft by criminal gangs who
are visiting who are using
these proceeds to raised to fund further
criminal activity
does the minister agree that we
have to
bring forward legislation on this as
quickly as possible we cannot delay any
further and can mr give us a clear time
scale on when we're going to see this
legislation and we can vote on this
important legislation in this house
well mr speaker the honourable gentleman
is is absolutely right uh that
unfortunately one of the effects of the
pandemic particularly the rise and the
value of pets particularly dogs and cats
who have been happily in demand by many
families who look to them for
companionship has brought with it a
criminal phenomenon which we need to
address
the task force has made a number of
recommendations and while i can't
give the honourable gentleman an
absolute timetable today he has our
undertaking that we are keen to move as
swiftly as possible uh to give him the
opportunity to put this offence on the
statute book sam bench thank you mr
speaker i like um other honourable
members here i'm honored to ask this
question in the memory of sir david i
met with local residents concerned about
their pet theft recently in hamburg my
constituency includes south and what
message would the minister give
to those constituents who have been
worried about this issue locally
well mr speaker it's typical of the
honourable gentleman that he would
gather his constituents together to give
voice to their concern in this area
i think the message that i would give
them is that we recognize their distress
and concern
as a dog and a cat owner ourselves it's
inconceivable that our pets
might be stolen and the damage and
trauma that they caused to my family if
that awful event were to to happen um is
very keenly in our mind uh the policy
development work in this particular
offence has now begun
and as i said earlier we hope uh to
bring legislation forward as quickly as
possible so that he and the many other
members
um who are very interested in this
subject and recognize the distress
that's being caused in communities up
and down the land by this crime can
exercise their free democratic will and
put the offense on the statute
mr speaker we currently have no plans to
reschedule psilocybin to schedule two of
them issues of drugs regulations the
advisory council on the misuse of drugs
has recently published stage one of its
advice in reducing barriers to research
with controlled drugs
we will consider the advice including
its implications for psilocybin
carefully before responding
crisp and blunt
thank you mr speaker
does my writing will friend understand
the emerging potential of the
psychedelic class of drugs uh with
psilocybin to the fore to treat
depression
trauma and addiction now family science
was emerging in the 1960s um before our
current drug laws closed it down
last year or in 2019
90
503 of our fellow citizens
were driven to suicide by their
depression or trauma or whose rock
bottom in addiction
uh has been death
if there is
any
uh scale of potential for these drugs
and it appears that there is
any further delay in getting the science
and the research gain is not defensible
in fact it's a morally disgraceful
abrogation of our duty to the public
good
well mr speaker as a founder of the all
party group on on life sciences i am
well aware
of the potential of any number of
compounds uh to assist us um in the
constant battle against mental and
physical illness and the need for this
country to lead
in research that might alleviate the
problem not just here
but in the rest of the
world but the honourable general will
know
that in particular where it comes to
rescheduling of
particular compounds we do so where
medicines are approved on the advice of
the mrha
and of the acmd
he will know for example that in june
last year
we did place epidiolex which is a
cannabis-based medicine used to treat
certain forms of epilepsy in schedule
five to the misuse of drug regulations
following exactly that sort of advice uh
there are ongoing trials and research
studies into silas i've been taking
place into the uk
and while a medicine has yet to be
licensed by the mhra if and when it is
we will consider research
thanks mr speaker just to catch up what
they were saying there could the
minister actually tell me what research
the uk government is basing this current
policy regarding silos cyber on and can
that research be made available
well mr speaker the research has been
undertaken in a number of um academic uh
institutions as far as i'm aware and i'm
happy to dig out the detail of where
specifically i don't have it to hand it
is being researched but it's worth
reinforcing uh mr speaker that the
process
for the rescheduling compounds is that
um approval is given for a medicine by
the mhra
advice is then taken from the acmd as
the rescheduling as we did do with
epidialex and as soon as those medicines
are
approved by the mhra for for use i would
be happy to consider rescheduling
very much mr speaker question number six
mr speaker i would like to associate
myself with the comments made by my
ministerial front bench colleagues on
the sad loss of our dear colleagues
with your permission i would like to
group this question with question 14 and
supporting victims of domestic abuse is
a government priority building on the
landmark domestic abuse act and the
tackling violence against women and
girls strategy published this year we
will also publish a dedicated domestic
abuse strategy and this strategy will
drive action to prevent offending
support victims relentlessly pursue
perpetrators and strengthen the system
as a whole
click drummond thank you very much mr
speaker and can i place on record on
behalf of my mian valley constituents
and myself are deep and utter shock
about the death of
david amos and also that of james
brockenshire and can i pass on their
deepest condolences to his family
constituents and many families and their
friends here and outside westminster
in hampshire over the last year there
were 26
785 domestic abuse offenses recorded
with the first period of lockdown
showing a 14 increase year-on-year
would my right-hand brefen continue her
support for police and crime
commissioners like donna jones in
hampshire who are attacking this
dreadful crime as a priority
well can i thank donna jones for the way
that she has prioritized
this crime backed by an uplift uplift in
the hampshire police funding settlement
and i can assure her that we'll be
working closely with police and
colleagues including police and crime
commissioners and the new policing lead
for tackling violence against women and
girls maggie blythe to drive forward
improvements in policing's response to
these crimes furthermore we'll be
publishing a refreshed national
statement of expectations on violence
against women and girls to support local
commissioners including pccs in
commissioning effective services
mr speaker anyone can be a victim of
domestic abuse regardless of gender age
ethnicity religion social economic
status sexuality or background but how
many men have been subjected to domestic
abuse and what is offered to them
differently to women
well my honorable friend is of course
absolutely right that men and boys can
be victims of domestic abuse and indeed
these other crimes that fall under the
umbrella of what we call violence
against women and girls and for the year
ending march 2020 the crime survey of
england of wales estimated that
757 000 men experience domestic abuse
which is approximately seven in 100 men
so we have done a lot of work to publish
the first ever cross-government male
victims position statement to strengthen
our response we do need to refresh the
male victims position statements and we
do also fund the men's advice line run
by respect to provide specialist support
to these victims so desmond sweden
mr speaker may i also associate myself
with the tributes that have been made
and will no doubt be made for the rest
of the day to both sir david and to
james brockenshire they were model
parliamentarians and great friends and
we're far poorer in this house for their
passing
mr speaker with your permission i would
like to group this question with
question 16
illegal entry to the uk via small boat
is unsafe unfair and unacceptable
we are working tirelessly to make this
route unviable through a comprehensive
package of measures there is no one
single answer our new plan for
immigration and the nationality and
borders bill will address the challenge
of illegal immigration by increasing
maximum sentences for people smugglers
and making it easier to swiftly remove
those who enter the uk illegally
so doesn't swain what urgency does he
attach to the implementation of offshore
processing along the australian model
well i'm very grateful to my right
honourable friend for his question and
he will know that the provisions in the
bill are comprehensive they are many and
varied as i say there is not one single
answer to the challenge that we face in
relation to these illegal crossings
across the channel we must make that
route unviable and of course we reserve
the right within the bill to do exactly
what he is advocating
thank you speaker does my honourable
friend agree with me that the
nationality and borders bill is
absolutely key to stopping the vile
people smuggling the gangs from
continuing to facilitate these channel
crossings and putting so many lives at
risk
well of course as ever he gets to the
nub of the issue and as i say i make the
point again because it bears repeating
that there is no one single answer
to resolving these challenges but what
we do require in swift order is the
measures that are set out in the bill
they're comprehensive they're there to
tackle these dangerous crossings of
course we need global assistance as well
to help us to achieve this but what we
must do is put these evil criminal gangs
out of business once and for all and
preserve human life that's exactly what
the measures we're proposing seek to do
absolutely
uh thank you mr speaker
i want to add my sincere condolences to
sir david emma's family and friends so
david was kind to everyone in parliament
and in he will be greatly missed
last week
sir david and i were part of elementary
delegation in qatar
during the visit we met the
unaccomplished child refugees who had
been evacuated from afghanistan and are
now being housed in a temporary
accommodation in qatar
as many as 13 of these children have
family members in the uk
and are desperate to be reunited with
the with them will the home secretary
now take steps to urgently facilitate
the reunion of these children with their
families
well i'm very grateful to the honourable
gentleman for his question and of course
we are working
across government on these matters and i
know that there is engagement going on
through the foreign commonwealth and
development office with the authorities
that he describes of course we have a
proud record a proud tradition in this
country of providing sanctuary for those
who find themselves in desperate
circumstances that absolutely continues
to be the case that's a firm commitment
that this government has
perfectly in line with our proud
traditions in this country and i think
people across our country would expect
us to continue to do that and that's
exactly what we will do assembly
spokesperson stuart sue mcdonald thank
you mr speaker for me and from my
colleagues and from the bottom of our
hearts can we send our deepest
condolences to the family friends and
colleagues of both sides and james
brokenshire
it's fair to say that in short everyone
knew sir david and everyone liked and
respected him without exception and in
relation to james brokenshire i shadowed
him as immigration minister in my first
year in this place and he made my job
ten times tougher not only because of
his mastery of the brief but because he
too was impossible and not to respect
until i can believe
mr speaker at the last question session
the home secretary suggested i hadn't
read the borders bill when i said that
it would see uyghurs persecuted
christians and syrians fleeing war
prosecuted and sentenced to prison but i
have read it and that is precisely what
clause 37 will do i welcome the minister
to his place but if he doesn't want to
see uighurs persecuted christians and
syrians prosecuted and imprisoned will
he take that clause out of the bill
well i would expect nothing less from um
the honourable gentleman given that
we're beginning line by line
consideration tomorrow in committee and
i've no doubt that he will have studied
every single clause um very very
carefully and will be interrogating me
on each of them um look we don't want to
see anybody um persecuted and as i've
said previously it as a country and as a
government we are absolutely determined
to make sure that they continue to be
safe and liveable roots so that people
can continue to
access sanctuary in this country where
people qualify and of course through our
international engagement we always press
home that human rights must be respected
and upheld at every turn
john burrow
thank you mr speaker um i
very much warmly welcome the minister
and indeed the government's um
forthcoming legislation on this issue
but can i urge him to take the utmost
haste and speed and delivering it to
this house for for our consideration the
to the trade if you like
of
human trafficking is a hideous crime
lives are being lost now
it's making a laughing stock i would
suggest of the two systems on both sides
of the channel we need to put a stop to
this it should not be beyond the width
of the government
that it be so
well i'm very grateful to my honourable
friend who has consistently been raising
these matters and he is right to say
that we want to deliver the provisions
of the nationality and borders bill as
quickly as possible because we believe
that they are fundamental to preventing
these dangerous channel crossings as
part of an overall package
to deliver on that and um i hope that
the bill will command support from
across the house he's also right to
raise the issue of collaboration with
our international partners and of course
the french are integral to that we have
an arrangement with the french it is
bearing results there is clearly still
more to do but it is the case mr speaker
that this issue cannot be resolved
entirely without that collaboration
mr speaker no illicit drug can be
assumed to be safe
mccarthy
right um i want to echo the tributes
obviously to sir david amos and to um
james spokenshire and my concentration
to their friends and family
the
over a single weekend in bristol this
summer one young person died and 20
others were hospitalized leading to
police warnings about a lethal batch of
pills circulating in the city and it's
just not enough for the government to
say don't do drugs that clearly doesn't
work so will the government work with
organizations like in the loop that do
provide testing or provide its own drugs
testing service like the welsh
government has been doing since 2014.
that's the only way that you're going to
save lives
well mr speaker we're obviously all
distressed to hear the news from bristol
and any life lost to drugs is obviously
to be mourned
anyone interested in lawfully
undertaking activities include the
possession supply or production of
controlled drugs including in the course
of drug testing services can already
apply to the homeowners for a domestic
licence
when they will be subject to usual
visits and considerations about the
activities that they
undertake
but i do
understand the
honourable ladies implication that we
should look at this subject in the round
and it is our hope that we'll publish a
comprehensive cross-government strategy
on drugs
as i say in the round um and their
impact on what we can do about them
later this year
we now go to laura phones
benign mr speaker
cases including the sickening murder of
sarah everard and the appalling murders
of bieber henry and nicole smallman have
caused immense pain and understandably
prompted huge concerns that's why the
home secretary commissioned an
inspection of the police response to
violence against women and girls and we
supported the recommendation to appoint
a full-time national policing lead to
drive forward progress on this hugely
important issue
thank you mr speaker i also want to
extend my deepest sympathies to the
families of sir david amos and james
brokenshire south end has lost two sons
and we've lost two very special
parliamentary colleagues
i'd also like to recognize the work that
my right honourable friend the home
secretary has been doing
over the last few very challenging weeks
which have had damaging implications for
the relationship between the police and
the safety of women last week the times
reported that of
disciplinary hearings that have been
conducted over the last three years over
half were held in private and almost no
force published the findings we know how
important transparency is when it comes
to public confidence so could my
honourable friend say what steps she is
taking to ensure that members of the
public can see what is going on with
their local force
well my honorable friend is absolutely
right that public confidence in the
policing response is vital in tackling
violence against women and girls and i'm
determined as a home secretary to do all
we can to combat these sickening crimes
we are committed to ensuring that
policing is subject to stringent levels
of transparency and accountability
misconduct hearings are chaired
independently of forces by legally
qualified chairs
sometimes those hearings must be held in
private for several legitimate reasons
but we will be looking at this matter
further to make sure that the system is
accountable to the public
shadow minister jasmine
thank you mr speaker obviously
we all on this side of the house wish to
be associated with the words of the home
secretary and
um send our love and best regards to sir
david's family he was kind and
good
but for me
above all else he was funny
and he didn't take himself too seriously
and as for james
as the immigration minister he was
incredibly approachable and kind and
a good and thorough minister i wish also
just to briefly say from this side of
the house who know how it feels to have
someone fall
our love through you mr speaker is with
all of those friends and colleagues of
those who have died
um i simply rise to ask the minister if
her department have decided if they are
going to implement all the
recommendations and the time frame laid
out in her majesty's inspectorate of
policing report last month in order to
improve our national response to
violence against women and girls in
september the minister told this house
that the home secretary has committed to
considering the report's full
recommendations and will update
parliament when she has done so an
update on that position would be
welcomed
well i thank the honourable lady for her
words
just now
and clearly the report that has been
produced is a very important report and
the home secretary and the home office
are considering that in detail we have
already put into place a number of very
important actions including appointing
detective chief constable maggie blythe
and also chairing a new task force to
drive cross-government action
the home secretary has also announced an
independent inquiry into the issues
surrounding wayne cousins and wider
culture in policing and she will update
the house very soon
cole locker
question tam
thank you mr speaker
when we introduced the new skilled
worker visa last year we broadened the
skills threshold from the academically
focused graduate level under the
previous tier 2 visa to school lever
level rqf3 to ensure a wider range of
skilled work was recognised this change
means roles such as butcher farmer and
poultry processors qualified for the
skilled worker group allowing
recruitment on a global level into them
colin lockhart
thank you mr speaker and can i extend my
thoughts and prayers to sir david amos
and james brokenshire's family friends
colleagues and staff today and i trust
that i will have the opportunity to
speak later
further on this matter
mr speaker i thank the home secretary
for meeting with myself and party
colleagues on this issue
just a short number of weeks ago and for
the actions taken
since then to alleviate the labour
supply pressures however i do fear the
short window of opportunity being
offered will not be enough to attract
the necessary workers additionally our
farmers particularly our pig farmers are
in crisis as we speak in this house
today what additional efforts are being
made alongside defra
to support this industry meet the
pressing demand for labour with farms
backing up with healthy pigs and
abattoirs cancelling 25
of their pig slaughter due to staff
shortages
well i'm grateful to the um honourable
lady for her supplementary question and
i know that she met the home secretary
recently to talk about this and of
course events have moved on since and
we've had flexibility on visas obviously
the issues around cold storage are being
addressed but what is clear is that this
is a short-term fix not a long-term
solution and i think what we must do is
continue to focus and i think people in
our country would really expect us to
focus on what more we can do to make
sure that we improve skills and training
and wages and terms and conditions to
make sure that the domestic labor market
is able to fulfill these roles in the
longer term but we have been responsive
to industries asks and of course our is
continue to be open peterborough
thank you mr speaker
it would have been very appropriate
today um david amos would be the first
to welcome the humanness of the dispatch
box
because the three of us worked together
on grassworks out and he held the first
rally for us and it's appropriate to
this question isn't it right minister
that the european coming out of the
european union gives us the ability to
decide on these
issues well thank you to my um honorable
friend and neighbor for his question and
um
it won't surprise him to hear that um
only a couple of weeks ago i received a
note from sir david congratulating me on
my appointment and it's something that i
will absolutely treasure um in the years
ahead his encouragement was always
second to none um the truth is that um
people like he and i campaigned in the
referendum for a global immigration
system that is exactly what we have
delivered i genuinely believe that that
is the right approach to immigration for
the years ahead based on skills
recruiting the skills that we need but
also making sure that we do right by the
domestic labor market and people in this
country by increasing skills increasing
opportunity increasing training terms
and conditions and making sure that more
readily we can recruit to those roles
shadow minister van mossorov
thank you mr speaker
and i too wish to pay my tributes to sir
david and james brokenshire and pastor
mighty's condolences and sympathies to
their families uh they're two of the
kindest most decent parliamentarians
i've ever met
and i will certainly miss my
conversations with sir david by
the lifts in one parliament street
always with a smile
uh mr speaker um the national farmers
union have told mps that there's a
chronic shortage of butchers and
agriculture workers which has led to 150
000 pigs being backed up on farms
so i submitted will the government add
the butchers and agricultural workers to
the shortage occupation list and will
the government agree to review the list
earlier than 2022 as is the current plan
well the
honorable gentleman um raises an
interesting question and he should know
that of course the home office and
ministers in the home office are working
constructively with defra who of course
are regularly engaging no doubt with the
national farmers union
around these matters and following last
year's max soul review the government
set out its response to stating that the
labor market is changing as a result of
covid and that is important to assess
changes in the labor market before
making widespread changes to the sole
this is particularly true at a time when
so many british people still face
uncertain times with the ending of
furlough but as i say
we are committed we have taken steps in
the short term to address these
challenges that have been raised but
this really is not the long-term
solution to these challenges but of
course we're responsive as the situation
develops
thank you speaker while i wanted to take
the opportunity to welcome my friend to
his position on the front bench he might
not welcome what i have to say after i
congratulate an echo the
comments that he made in condolence of
our dear departed colleagues both david
and james um
so far we haven't had any facts and
figures um what are the numbers of
shortages how many applications have
been made and how many visas have been
granted
well thank you to my um
honorable friend um for his question um
as i say
what we have done is we've been
responsive to the needs that have arisen
in our economy we've been engaging with
the various sectors who've come forward
to raise concerns for example
there is a commitment to supporting
visas for 4 700 htv food drivers up to 5
500 poultry workers 300 fuel drivers and
i think the key thing now is that those
industries who've sought that extra
support and that flexibility through
visas now get on and recruit to those
roles
cut smith
question 11.
thank you mr speaker and i i too wish to
associate with your words and the home
secretaries in memory of our
two cherished friends david and james
outstanding parliamentarians both
james of course among his many other
accomplishments was also a an
exceptionally effective and highly
respected security minister in which
well he set the enduring example and as
well as colleagues in this house he is
very much missed by officials in the
home office and by the agencies and
partners with which he worked
mr speaker online fraud and scams have a
devastating impact and we are taking
action to protect the public and make it
harder for fraudsters to operate and the
online safety bill will tackle some of
the highest harm forwards online that's
smooth
thank you mr speaker and i was put on
record um my own condolences to the
families of james brokenshire and sir
david and a lot of people have said that
sir david was a good support to new mps
but he was also a good support to those
of us who were doing things for the
first time and indeed he chaired the
first bill committee where i was uh on
the opposition front bench and he was a
great support to me and will be dearly
missed from this house
many of my fleetwood constituents are
seriously concerned about pension scams
which are on the rise and i pay tribute
to the work of age uk for the awareness
that they're raising about the risk of
pension scams as the kind of minister
tell me what steps and he plans to take
in terms of the online harms bill
specifically on pension scams
so mr speaker the honourable lady is
exactly right to identify the the
wickedness of pension scams picking on
people
often at a time of weakness part of a
wider
wider field of investment scams as she
will know the online safety bill is
currently going through pre-legislative
scrutiny which is an opportunity for
issues to be fleshed out which is
absolutely right government focus
remains very much also on on the pension
scams that she mentions
trisha believes
can i express my steep sadness
to david amos and james brokenshire
and can i also ask the minister
what action the government and the
police are taking to protect the elderly
in particular from scans it's one of the
most repellent aspects of this type of
crime that the criminals particularly
prey on the elderly and vulnerable
yes i thank my right angle friend for
that question that follows on of course
from what the honorable lady opposite
was uh was saying it's very important
that we raise awareness of how to
protect yourself about against these
scams the things to look out for that we
encourage reporting so that we can build
up a wider picture it's also very
important that we focus on victim
support when these clients have occurred
and to prevent re-victimization and
we're increasing our efforts in that
area gentlemen again again
thank you mr speaker can i echo what has
been said about sir david amos when it
comes to james brokenshire quite simply
he was everything you'd have wanted in
an opposite number he was cooperative
constructive but occasionally a
combative
and i will miss him i congratulate the
new security minister and i think we've
already established a similar working
relationship
online harms have been brought sharply
into focus during the last 18 months
fraud and scams but also extremism
radicalization and terrorism the police
security and intelligence services are
very concerned and we sadly know the
tragic consequences is the minister
satisfied that he can address this in
the online safety bill or our specific
and perhaps more urgent actions required
can i assure them that if they are we
will seek to work with the government in
finding common ground to bring forward
any necessary measures
well i'm going to start by thanking
the honorable gentleman twice over first
of all for what he said at the start but
also for his expressions of support for
doing what we need to do to make sure
that
these terrible
terrible messaging propaganda
and ways of association with the most
horrific
outcomes and consequences they can have
that we that we disrupt them um and that
we that we thwart these efforts
there is um there are important steps in
the online safety bill to do with
illegal content i think that will
improve
our arsenal our toolkit but there are
other things we need to work on as well
in particular the issue of end-to-end
equipment and the deliberate blinding of
platforms to themselves against being
able to take down
very harmful materials something which i
look forward to working with him
mr speaker may i pay respects on behalf
of the people of stroud to the families
of sir david and james brokenshire on
the bbc yesterday my right honourable
friend the home secretary was compelling
when she spoke about the challenges of
tackling anonymous abuse and
understanding that the public are
looking to us to to make changes here
will my right honourable friend meet
with me to discuss my verification
campaign with a group um clean up the
internet to see how your department can
also assist this work
mr speaker i'll certainly meet with my
honorable friend and recognize that
she's done a lot of work in this area i
do want to make very clear to people
that where they are engaged in illegal
abuse they can be identified and they
can be prosecuted via existing
legislation police and criminal criminal
evidence act of 84 and investigatory
powers act 2016 but i do accept there
are more aspects of this and i'm very
happy uh to meet with her and look
forward to hearing her thoughts
we now go to topicals
number one mr speaker
thank you mr speaker
the whole country is horrified and
shaken by the dreadful killing of our
colleague and friends to david amos
there's been a tidal wave of stories
about david's kindness and compassions
from all quarters
and to me he was a dear and loyal friend
we are all utterly devastated for
david's wife julia and their family and
loved ones
david mr speaker as we've already heard
across the house had a huge number of
friends in this house
in his constituency in the county of
essex and well beyond
the causes he supported we've heard were
diverse and so many both relating to
people and of course much-loved animals
and many sessions in this house were
enlivened mr speaker by his calls for
city status for south end
he's agonizing to know that we will not
see his wonderful smile again
and it took no effort on david's part to
conduct the business of politics in a
civilized good humid way which came
naturally to him decency ran through him
like the writing in a stick of south end
rock
david represented all that was good
about this place so let us all carry his
light forward and reflect his passionate
commitment to making things better for
the people we serve
[Applause]
can i can i pay my respects to sir david
amis and james wilkinshire and send my
best wishes to his family his friends
and his staff mr speaker today on
anti-slavery day statistics obtained by
after exploitation show that since 2016
over four and a half thousand suspected
trafficking victims have only been
referred for support after leaving
immigration detention
this shows a major failing and
demonstrates how the trauma of detention
prevents victims from disclosing their
exploitation
so can the minister explain what work is
being carried out to tackle this problem
and also say why is the home office
still planning to open a new immigration
detention centre for women this month in
county durham
thank you mr speaker well first of all
on the really important point that she
has made around modern day slavery and
trafficking the government is absolutely
committed to undertaking every steps and
every measures to provide support
through the national referral mechanism
and also support in terms of victim
victimization through much of the modern
day slavery work that we do do as well i
should just like to reassure the
honourable lady mr speaker that actually
through the current borders of
nationality bill there is greater work
taking place now in terms of what kind
of measures we can put in place to
safeguard the victims safeguard their
testimony and make sure that they get
the support that they need i'm fletcher
thank you mr speaker mayor place on
record my own condolences to the
families of the two colleagues that we
have lost uh i recently undertook uh
residence surveys in heave and
childbrook in my constituency and it
showed that there was strong demand
for more bobbies on the beat to tackle
anti-social behavior can i ask my
honorable friend what progress we have
made in getting more police on the
streets in derbyshire yeah yeah yeah
well mr speaker can i commend the
honourable gentleman for engaging uh
with his constituents on what is very
often easily the most important subject
uh to close to all of our constituents
hearts he will be pleased to hear that
we are now approaching the halfway mark
on our twenty thousand extra police
officers which obviously represents a
gross recruitment of something over
twenty thousand and i hope that he will
feel the effect of the now well over a
hundred police officers recruited by
derbyshire constabulary on the streets
of his constituency in the weeks to come
shut the home secretary nick thomas
simmons
thank you mr speaker i first met sir
david amos when i entered this house in
2015 and when as a new member he
approached me to ask how i was and how i
was settling in
and that conversation captured the
essence of sir david who was a kind
thoughtful and generous man always
cheerful and smiling he was dedicated to
the service of his constituents he had
passionate beliefs and he worked across
party lines on causes that mattered to
him and those he served he was respected
and held in affection across the house
and we on these benches send condolences
to his wife julia to all of his loved
ones and parliamentary colleagues
sadly mr speaker another member of this
house james brokenshire was taken from
us too young i worked with james on a
number of security issues he was a man
of firm beliefs staunch integrity and
unfailing good humor he pursued causes
with passion and respect and represented
politics at its best and we on these
benches send sympathies to his wife
kathy and halley's loved ones and
parliamentary colleagues and also mr
speaker like to send
best wishes to lynn owens to thank her
for her work as director general of the
national crime agency and wish her a
swift recovery from her recent surgery
mr speaker i'm grateful to your office
under the home secretary for the work on
mp security since the heinous crime that
was committed on friday but i wonder if
the home secretary could offer some
further details on the review
can she confirm when the review she
announced will be completed and what she
will do too
to ensure that any recommendations are
applied consistently by police forces up
and down the country
well i thank my writing friend first of
all for his
comments regarding david james and lynn
as well lynn owens
these are important points obviously in
terms of members security which the
speaker and myself have been
working on over recent days and it is
absolutely right i think for all members
of the house to recognize that we want
to see consistency across the board when
it comes to the safety and security of
members of parliament and our ability to
conduct our public duties as
democratically elected members of this
house the review is underway right now
and i can confirm to my writing friend
and to all honorable and my trumbull
members that the police in review itself
is concluding literally over the next
few days there will be more
communications to all colleagues across
the house
in terms of how to conduct their work
publicly in a safe and secure way while
at the same time giving the public the
confidence and assurance that they need
when they are coming to meet members in
forums such as surgeries but also that
the one-to-one contact that members of
parliament require will be taking place
actually starting from this afternoon
nick thomason i'm grateful for that
answer and the awful murder of sir david
follows after the dreadful murder of our
friend joe cox an attack on my right
honourable friend a member east ham a
plot to kill my honourable friend the
memphis west lancashire and the murder
of andrew pennington who was killed
after attack at the office of the now
noble lord lord jones of cheltenham now
any attack on any elected representative
is an attack on our whole democracy and
it's with that imperative we have to
approach this mr speaker i appreciate
the current investigation is at a very
early stage and home secretary will
quite rightly be very guarded on
specifics but i wonder if you can
comment more broadly on the issue of
lone attackers can the home secretary
set out what steps the government
intends to take
to investigate this type of attack the
radicalization of perpetrators and will
the strategy be put in place to reduce
the risk of such attacks in future well
my rightful friend is absolutely right
in terms of the live investigation
taking place and i will not be drawn
into any commentary whatsoever and no
member should
the issue of lone attackers is not new
and across society and across our
country and other countries around the
world sadly we have seen too many lone
attackers in previous years as well
there is a great deal of work taking
place and sadly we you know we will
continue to discuss actually the work
across intelligence policing security
prisons and probation as well um the
work that takes place to prevent these
attacks but also the data and
intelligence sharing that um is
undertaken across our systems across
government but across all aspects of
various institutions and society linked
to of course some of the current
inquiries that are also taking place so
there's a great deal of work that is in
flight right now underway
but i also think it is important to
recognize and i would like all members
of the house to hear this
we have some of the best intelligence
and security agencies in the world i
want to pay tribute to them today and
our police forces for the work that they
have been doing specifically in regards
to the current investigation but also
the much wider work that they do to keep
us safe every single day
thank you mr speaker and i'd like to
associate myself with the remarks made
by yourself the home secretary and other
honourable members and paid tribute to
sir david amos and james birkenshire two
fantastic and honourable honorable mps
cruelly taken before their time and
their friends and families and all our
thoughts and prayers now on the review
of security of mps does my writing or
friend agree with me that one of the
things that makes our democracy great is
the unfettered access our constituents
have to us and that this must be
protected and strengthened as part of
this review
thank you honourable friend for his
question well for his comments and his
question he's absolutely right and i
think all of us all honourable mighty
humble members take pride in their
constituency work and exactly that the
ability for
constituents to approach us and for us
to be approachable to them
underway right now there are a number of
security reviews but practical
considerations that we are looking at
rightly to protect members and to
protect the public to enable us to carry
out our functions as democratically
elected members of this house smp
spokesperson stewart c mcdonald
thank you mr speaker having expressed
our condolences can we also express our
thanks both to you and the home
secretary for the work that's already
ongoing to review and improve our
security
i agree with the home secretary that we
must make it our mission both to improve
safety and to protect the close links
between the public and their
representatives but will she agree that
this must be true at all levels of
democracy and i mentioned in particular
our local councillors at the coalface
often doing surgeries alone week in and
weekend
russian friend is absolutely right and i
would just like to pay tribute actually
to all elected representatives across
the united kingdom because they do
conduct themselves day in day out um
with great determination and he is
writing there is work taking place just
to give the honorable gentleman in the
house assurance and through the cabinet
office that we actually look at the
right kind of measures and support them
i want to echo every comment that has
been made about david amos and james
brokenshire the introduction of damping
in 2004 to the police funding formula
has cost bedfordshire about 95 officers
on the beat will the government commit
to scrap damping as quickly as possible
to be fair to bedfordshire and the other
forces
affected and to do so as quickly as
possible
well mr speaker i've made a commitment
in this house before that we'll
introduce a new funding formula for
police
forces across the land before the next
election
that is the objective that we're
currently working towards although i
would uh warn everybody that all cannot
have prizes
thank you mr speaker
on behalf of my constituents and myself
i'd like to pass on my pupils
condolences to family of sir david amos
and james brokenshire mr speaker the
secretary of state will no doubt be
aware of the long-running extradition
cases of the west midlands three
two of whom are my constituents in
coventry northwest these three people
are british citizens and they have
endured raids arrest and imminent
threats of extradition given that the
crown's lawyers could present no case
whatsoever at the extradition
proceedings and the threats of
extradition is subsequently being
dropped would the secretary of state
outline exactly what evidence was used
to justify these arrests in the first
place and i'm sure the secretary of
state will agree that my constituents
deserve clear answers
speaker i'd like um to speak to the
honourable lady separately on this case
if i may because i didn't fully hear her
question but i will certainly follow up
on this extradition nigel mills
if i close i extend my condolences to
the family and friends of james and sir
david
over the recess the pandora papers
showed that corrupt and criminal money
is still making its way into the uk
and yet no unexplained wealth order has
been issued for the last two years could
the minister ensure that the national
crime agency has the resources to pursue
those orders in any case where they're
appropriate yeah yeah yeah
thank you mr speaker and unexplained
wealth orders are a very important tool
and yes we are absolutely making sure
that the resources are there to support
their use
thank you mr speaker i would like to
extend my condolences to sir david and
to james brockenshire's family and
friends
is the secretary of state aware that
victims of the windrush scandal are
disproportionately likely to be
suffering extreme hardship
will she publish guidance on its
expedition process for claims under the
scheme so that those in acute needs such
as my constituent anthony brian can
apply for the expedition
your lady will be well aware of the
extensive work that has taken place
around the windrush compensation scheme
and the support that we've offered her
constituent as well if she'd like to
meet with me to discuss this further
she'd be very welcome too
currently
mr speaker and i refer to my entry in
the register of memphis interest today
mr speaker we mark anti-slavery day
one of the first people in government to
recognize the importance of this issue
was our much-missed colleague james
brokenshire
will my right honourable friend please
confirm that her priority will be to
continue james's work making this a
priority for her and making the uk a
world leader in this area
tomball's friend is absolutely right in
the way and passionate way she's put her
question forward and we will continue
that work and the legacy of the work
that's taken place on modern-day slavery
no way from the plan
order in a moment i will ask the prime
minister to move the motion for the
adjournment of the house which will give
an opportunity for us to pay tribute to
sir david emis
as i said earlier the issues raised by
the circumstances of sir david's death
will be looted urgently and with the
utmost priority i would also remind
honorable and write all members that the
plea investigation is ongoing
so our focus this afternoon should be on
sir david's life and his contribution to
our democracy
in nearly four decades in this house sir
david was second to none
in his determined commitment to his
constituents firstly as the member for
basildon between 1983 and 97 and since
then as the member for southend west
he was a tireless in making sure the
voice of sophem west was heard in this
chamber it's difficult to believe that
we will not hear him make the case for
south end achieving city status
before the next recess definitely he
worked equally hard outside of the
chamber for his constituents always
going the extra mile to make sure their
case was heard and their needs were met
he used his skills as a parliamentarian
to pilot numerous pieces of legislation
onto the statue boots
reflecting his political priorities such
as fuel poverty and of course animal
welfare
he was much more admired as a member
of the panel of chairs respected across
this house for his furnace and expertise
i would also like to thank the speakers
from around the world
who sent messi of support
including speaker pelosi and
speaker smith of australia along with
many many more who wanted to let us know
that congress and the australian
parliament are thinking of us david's
family and all at this time
on a personal level
david was a lovely man
he was well liked by members and staff
alike
andrew is almost four decades here built
a reputation for kindness generosity
sustained by his faith
david was a devoted to his family as
much as we will miss a much fellow
parliamentarian the loss felt by david's
wife julia and their children is
unimaginable
i know the whole house will want to join
me in sending them our deepest
condolences
i now call the prime minister
mr speaker i beg to move that this house
do now adjourn
the passing year of 72 hours has done
little to numb the shock and sadness we
all felt
when we heard of the tragic and
senseless death of sir david
amos this house
has lost a steadfast servant
we've lost a dear friend and colleague
and julia and her children have lost a
loving husband and devoted father
nothing i
or anyone else can say will lessen the
pain
the grief
the anger
they must feel
at this darkest of times
we hold them
in our hearts today
we mourn with them
and we grieve alongside them
so david was taken from us in a
contemptible act of violence
striking at the core of what it is
to be a member of this house
and violating the sanctity both of the
church in which he was killed
and the constituency surgery that is so
essential to our representative
democracy
but we will not allow the manner of sir
david's death
in any way
to detract from his accomplishments as a
politician or as a human being
because david was a patriot who believed
passionately
in this country
in its people
in its future
he was also one of the nicest kindest
and most gentle individuals ever
to grace these benches
a man who used his decades of experience
to offer friendship and support to new
members of all parties
whose views often confounded expectation
and defied easy stereotype
and who believed not just in pointing
out what was wrong with society
but in getting on and doing something
about it
it was that determination
to make this country a better place
that inspired his outstanding record on
behalf
of the vulnerable
and the
voiceless the master of the private
member's bill and 10-minute rule bill
he passed legislation on subjects as
diverse as animal welfare fuel poverty
and the registration of driving
instructors
he was a prodigious campaigner for
children with learning disabilities and
for women with endometriosis
a condition on which he became an expert
after meeting a woman
at one of his constituency surgeries
behind the famous and irresistible beam
lay a seasoned campaigner a verve
and grit
whether he was demanding freedom for the
people of iran
or courting votes
in the westminster dog of the year
contest
whether he was battling for brexit or
fighting his way to the front of the
parliamentary pancake race
and as every member of this house well
known as you have just confirmed mr
speaker
he never once witnessed any achievement
by any resident of south end
that could not somehow be cited in his
bid to secure city status for that
distinguished time
[Applause]
highlights of that bulging folder
included a world record
for playing
the most triangles at once
a group of stilt walkers traveling
non-stop from the essex coast to downey
street
and a visiting foreign dignitary
allegedly
flouting protocol by saying he liked
south end
more than cleethorpes
a compelling case uh mr speaker
and as it is only a short time
since sir david last put that very case
to me in this chamber
i am happy to announce
that her majesty has agreed
that south end
will be accorded the city status it so
clearly deserves
[Applause]
that's a david spent almost 40 years in
this house
but not one day in ministerial office
tells everything about where his
priorities lay
he was not a man in all of this chamber
nor a man who sought
patronage or advancement
he simply wanted to serve the people of
essex
first in basildon then in south end
and it was in the act of serving his
constituents that he was so cruelly
killed
in his recent memoir
sir david called surgeries
a part of the great british tradition
of the people openly meeting their
elected politicians
even after
the murder of joe cox and the savage
attacks on stephen timms and nigel jones
he refused to accept that he should be
in any way deterred from speaking face
to face with his constituents
and so when he died
he was doing what he firmly believed was
the most important part
of any mp's job
offering help
to those
in need
in the awful moments before we knew the
full horror of the tragedy
a member
of sir david's constituency association
her voice breaking with emotion
told an interviewer
that we need him
the country
needs him and we do
this country needs people like sir david
this house needs people likes to david
and our politics needs people like sir
david
dedicated passionate firm in his beliefs
but never anything less than respectful
for those who thought differently
those are the values he brought to a
lifetime of public service
there can be few among us more justified
than him
in his deep faith
in the resurrection
and the life to come
and while his death
leaves a vacuum that will not
and can never be filled
we will
cherish
his memory
we will celebrate
his legacy
and we will never allow those who commit
acts of evil to triumph over the
democracy and the parliament that sir
david amos loved so much
the question is this host who noah john
i know called the leader of the
opposition dear stammer
thank you mr speaker
in the last few days there have been
many tributes to sir david
from politicians of all parties
from his constituents and members of the
public
from friends and from family
and from faith leaders especially the
catholic church of which he was such a
devoted follower
each tribute paints its own picture
of a committed public servant
of kindness
and of a man whose decency touched
everybody that he met
taken together these tributes are a
powerful testimony
to the respect
the affection and yes the love that
david was held in
across politics
and across different communities
together they speak volumes about the
man that he was
and the loss that we grieve
so david was a dedicated parliamentarian
and his loss is felt profoundly across
this house we are united in our grief
at this terrible time
we are thinking of david
and his family
we are thinking
once again
of our dear friend joe cox who was
killed just five short years ago
and i know the honourable members and
their staff will have spent the weekend
worrying about their own safety
the emotion is the same across the house
but i remember just how acutely joe's
loss was felt on these benches
so today
on behalf of the entire labour party
i want to lean across
to reach across
and to acknowledge
the pain that's felt
on the opposite benches and i do
of course our differences matter after
all that's what democracy is about
but today we're reminded that what we
have in common matters far more
i spoke to joe cox's parents on friday
afternoon
because i knew that they would be
reliving that terrible day
they said to me
they were thinking of david's family
and how their lives would be changed
forever
so today just the prime minister has
said this house holds in our hearts
david's wife julia
his children catherine david junior
sarah florence and alex
and all of those
who loved him
we cannot begin to imagine
what they're going through
but our thoughts
our love
and our prayers
are with them
i also thank those who did everything
they could to save david's life and our
emergency services
who run towards danger to protect us
and i just want to take a moment
to think about
for all of us to think about
david's staff
and what they
must be going through
this parliament that david loved so much
has lost one of its finest advocates
his colleagues have lost a dear friend
and the people of south end have lost
one of their own
so david was a dedicated constituency mp
when i visited south end on saturday i
was struck by the affection and the
regard that he was held in by everybody
i met
he rejected ministerial office to focus
on south end
and we remember his historic battle to
see it given city status and i'm so
pleased at the announcement the prime
minister has just made
it is a fitting tribute to sir david's
hard work it really is
fitting
because david delivered on the causes he
championed he cared about them he passed
a bill that forced action on fuel
poverty
he paved the way for better standards of
fire safety
and delivered protections for animal
welfare and no tribute has emerged in
recent days that resonates more vividly
than that of his former parliamentary
staffer edward holmes
as he was in his first job out of
university holmes forgot to tell sir
david about an urgent call that the then
prime minister david cameron had made
he said he felt terrified until he
finally plucked up the courage to tell
david
whose response
was typical
don't worry about that edward
so relaxed was david that mr holm says
he suspects he never actually called the
prime minister back
that tells a politician who had his
priorities right
one who put his people before his party
and his patch before his personal
advancement
even as a political opponent he was a
man and a politician we can all learn so
much from
i use that phrase political opponent
very deliberately
because david held his beliefs
passionately
but gently
and i believe that not only can we learn
from that
but we have a duty
to learn from that
civility matters
and it matters in politics
we must not lose sight of the fact that
david's killing was an act of terror in
our country
we can't help
today but think of joe cox
andrew pennington
and pc keith palmer
who lost his life defending all of us in
this place in 2017
and we thank god that the honourable
member for east ham is with us in the
chamber today
and that the honourable member for west
lancashire's would-be attackers were
stopped in their tracks
and i know that politicians
across the country across this house
have their own experiences of threats to
their security
today is a chance to remember david
but in the weeks and days to come we
must confront the threats and violence
that everyone faces enacting this
country's democracy
it's too early for us to comment on the
exact motivations and circumstances of
david's killing
but i do want to finish by saying this
a cowardly attack
on a public servant doing his job
is an attack on our country and on our
way of life
a way of life that prizes tolerance
democracy and respect
that accepts our differences but
cherishes our commonalities
that refuses to succumb to the poison of
extremism
no matter what perverted cause
faith faithful ideology these attackers
support
their intention is always the same
to sow division amongst us
and that's why our response must always
be
to show that we will never be cowed
that our bonds to one another can never
be eroded
that the hatred that took said david's
life
will never win
our democracy is precious it's held firm
against many tests
but it's also a fragile living thing
let us use the memory of david's life
and his passions to nourish it
to recommit ourselves in standing for
the things that he stood for
the things that extremists will never
comprehend
for decency in our disagreements
for kindness
in our hearts
for our great democracy
and for the hope
that through it
we can make our country
and our world
a better place
mark francois
thank you mr speaker
sir david amos was my best and oldest
friend in politics
so i confess that i'm hurting terribly
and i hope the house will therefore
forgive me if because of that
my contribution this afternoon is even
more incoherent than usual
i certainly cannot match those two
beautiful and if i may so extremely
moving tributes
from the prime minister and the leader
of the opposition
thank you
everything i ever learned about how to
be a constituent cmp i learned from
david amos
he sponsored me for the candidates list
and he mentored me when i arrived
without him i would never have become a
member of the palm
so some might well argue he has much to
answer
i grew up in basildon when david was the
local mp i grew up on a working-class
council estate which even the locals
nicknamed alcatraz
david helped me to campaign in 1991 to
win election on to basildon council
quite a robust place to learn your trade
once described as the only local
authority in britain where at council
meetings the council has actively
heckled the public gallery
i was there
trust me i'm a politician
i ran his in return i ran his ground war
in his iconic defense of basildon
in 1992 during that campaign mr speaker
the late paul channel
came down from south end to help and we
were out canvassing on a council estate
in pitsy i'll never forget it
we knocked on this door and this monster
of a bloke opened the door and he looked
at us both and he looked at the blue
rosettes and he said
conservative
tory
you must be bloody joking
i'm voting for that david ames
and i said i know when i'm beat sir well
done
and my partner olivia alive would you to
be on his table at the south and west
conservatives
annual dinner on the day that he was
called
but david is now our fallen comrade sir
he was a devoted and a loving family man
and our deepest sympathies are with his
widow lady julia
and his five children
who produced the most amazingly
courageous statement yesterday
the essence of which i think was that
love must conquer hate
and i'm sure sir we all agree with that
he was an animal
a patriot
a thatcherite a euro skeptic
a monarchist and a staunch roman
catholic
whose faith sustained him throughout his
life
and he was a truly great friend in need
i can vouch for that
and a fine parliamentary
he was probably the best potential
father of the house we will now never
have
he had a zest for life he had a joy
believe
for him the glass was never half empty
it was three quarters full
he was a dowty champion for basildon and
then for south end
so thank you prime minister and her
majesty
and the privy council for making south
endless city
it was the right thing to do absolutely
and our apologies to cleveland
[Laughter]
while you're at it if you can help south
end united they're having a bit of a
they really need all the help they can
get
but you never knew what david was going
to do next
that essex cheeky chatty smile
that impish amos grin
always was some hint of gentle mischief
standing behind it he once even
persuaded his holiness the pope to bless
a boiled sweet
but my right my friend and neighbor will
explain in a moment mr smith
but he did have a serious side too
and it's on that which i really want to
focus the rest of my contribution today
in the last few years david had become
increasingly concerned about what he
called the toxic environment
in which mps particularly female mps
were having to operate
he was appalled by what he called the
vile misogynistic abuse
which female mps had to endure online
and he told me very recently that he
wanted something done about
three years ago three years
my right honourable friend for mid
bedfordshire wrote a powerful article
about this on conservative home in which
she quoted the following social media
post
i want to see you
trapped in a burning car
and watch the heat from the flames as
they melt the flesh from your face
i ask you mr speaker what did she do to
ever deserve that
another fallen comrade
joe cox
whose sister now graces this place
said we have more in common than divides
us
and i think she was absolutely right
mr speaker
all of us wherever we come from came
here to try and help people
we may disagree sometimes passionately
about how best
to help people
but surely we can all agree that we came
here to try
yeah
for which we are now systematically
vilified
day after day and i simply say to you
ladies and gentlemen
that enough is enough
because we all have absolutely one thing
in common
we are legislators
so i humbly suggest mr speaker we get on
and do some legislating
i suggest that if we want to
ensure that our colleague didn't die in
the vein
we collectively all of us pick up the
batten regardless of our party
and take the forthcoming online harms
bill and toughen it up
so let's put if i may be so presumptuous
david's law
onto the statute
the essence of which would be that while
people in public life must remain open
to legitimate criticism they can no
longer be vilified or their family is
subject to the most horrendous abuse
especially from people who hide behind a
cloak of anonymity
with the connivance of the social media
companies for profit
the mood i'm in mr speaker
i confess i'd like to drag mark
zuckerberg of facebook and jack dorsey
of twitter to the bar of the house if
necessary kicking and screaming so they
can look us all in the eye and account
for their actions
or rather their inactions
which make them even richer than they
already are
and let's do that for all of our
counselors
who are sick and tired of reading on
facebook
after every planning committee the night
before that well it must have been a
brown envelope job
let's do it for all those other people
who hold surgeries
for gps
who have carried on tending to the sick
throughout the pandemic but who are now
being vilified online along with their
loyal receptionists and staff just for
trying to do their job
and if the social media companies don't
want to help us drain the twitter swamp
then let's compel them to do it
by law
because they've had more than enough
chances to do it voluntarily
so please bring in this bill promised
and if you need any assistance in
toughening it up we're called the
backbenchers of the house of commons and
we're here to help
what better way to ensure that a fine
parliamentarian did not die in vain
than to enshrine one of his last wishes
in legislation
forever
for the benefit of all of those in
public
there are many who wish to pay tributes
mr speaker so i'll end with this
another thing about david was his
legendary timekeeping
or rather the lack of it
he was so popular that his constituency
events always ran late there were so
many people who always wanted to speak
to him
so by the end of a constituency a busy
constituency friday of which he had many
he was sometimes running up to an hour
late
he invariably overran
and so in his honor this afternoon so
i'm afraid have it
[Laughter]
sorry
but because of this wonderful trait what
better fault to have than that
among some of his closest friends he was
known affectionately as the late sir
david
well now he really is the latest david
but i am absolutely determined that i
ask for your supportiveness
that he will not have died in vain
he's now resting
in the arms of the god he worshipped so
devotedly his whole life
so fair well then
my colleague
my great friend
in fact quite simply the best bloke i
ever knew
i thank the house for it
i know come to leader of the smp in
blackfood
thank you mr speaker and it's a
considerable pleasure to follow the
honourable member for really and
whitford and i have to say
and i don't think i've ever said this
after any of these contributions i
pretty well
agree with every single
word he said and i hope the house does
listen very carefully to what he said
and the responsibilities that we
that we all have
mr speaker
we are gathered here
united in mourning and grief at the loss
of a
proud champion of south end of
now to be the city of south end
a great backbencher
a beloved husband
and a father and dear friend to so many
particularly on the government benches
so david amos was valued in so many ways
but i think the most powerful
description he achieved was in some ways
was the simplest and the most human
david
was above all else
a good
and a deeply decent man
a man that would always greet you with a
welcoming smile
whenever you met him
for members and staff across this house
it will take time to come to terms with
the terrible shock
of the senseless loss
of another colleague
because
just as our thoughts and prayers today
are with the entire ambush family we
think two of the
family of joe cox who are forced to
relive the nightmare
of their experience all over again mr
speaker
members of this house
are being murdered
while simply doing their job
that is the
terrible reality that we are faced with
and just as we
face it together we need to put an end
to it together
and providing that security and safety
we need to protect all those at risk
because
we all know that it's often our staff
who are at the very front line of the
threats and the abuse as well
so i welcome the review underway into mp
security but i would generally urge the
home secretary to also include our staff
as a central part of that security
review
the devastating loss of sir david has
once again laid bare that twin threat of
terrorism
and the toxic culture of hate
and intolerance that has become all too
common
so today of all days
it is crucial that we show the same
spirit and speak
with one voice across this house as
indeed
we are doing
i
stand firmly
with an echo the powerful and poignant
words of both the prime minister
and the leader of the opposition
but i also want to commend them for
jointly going and standing together in
south end on saturday
that was exactly the right image
and the right message to send
people need to see that image of unity
and saturday and it is an image and
ethos of political leadership that we
need to project in public
far more often
a healthy democracy that engages with
passionate disagreement as appropriate
but we all know that somewhere along the
way
we have been badly diverted for too long
we have been dragged down a path where
passionate disagreement
has been infected by poison
all of us can do better not to feed into
that corrosive culture all of us have
been a victim of it and every single one
of us
have a responsibility to put an end to
it
it is the truest tribute to sir david
that he personified exactly
what we need to get to he was a person
whose politics could be forceful
but always a friendly a person who could
disagree
without ever
not ever being disagreeable
for the rest of this session i look
forward to hearing the fond memories
from
many of his colleagues and friends
the beautiful statement released by the
amos family last night put it better
than i possibly could david's lesson and
his legacy is to show kindness and love
to all
all of our memories will be of a good
man and of a life well-lived
may his family and community today know
that the true depth of respect affection
and love that he enjoyed across this
house
and may his gentle soul
now rest in peace
god bless you david
james
david was a man of faith and convictions
faith in his religion
and convictions in his politics
he was above and beyond everything else
a family man and a very funny man
he'd often break all the rules cutting
through pomp and ceremony and connecting
with people when introducing me he'd
always make up a story
i was the strictly come dancing winner
at his annual party for people over the
age of 100
before there was ever a raffle he'd
described me as a lottery millionaire at
charity fundraiser
my favorite ice breaker is meet james
he's my neighbor he's recently got out
of prison
he'd hold the audience with his
anecdotes and stories and and i would
like to share the uh the the story of
the boiled sweet
david was a regular visitor to the
vatican given his faith and in the
receiving line perhaps slightly
absent-mindedly being used to these
things people were getting items blessed
david having a sore throat reached into
his pocket for a boiled sweep
david got his timing wrong the pope took
the sweet thinking it was a revered
object
to be blessed
blessed the revered object
and david had to put it in his pocket
a holy sweet a holy sweet and when david
would tell the anecdote as he would do
many a time i suspect you've all heard
it he'd again reach into his pocket and
say and this is the sweet i was blessed
mr speaker i i suspect there have been
many speeches passed off as the holy
sweet but there is only one chosen one
as the neighbouring member of parliament
for what we now must say is southend
city and thank you prime
minister means a lot to everybody it
really does
um people would sidle up to me
colleagues would sidle up to me and say
you're david's neighbor aren't you and
i'm like a bit sensitive yes
but i knew what was coming it was always
an outrageous story of his behavior at a
meeting or particularly on overseas
trips that just completely broke the ice
he was indeed a great man
he loved animals
but there will no longer be the infamous
dog of the day tweets
he would never again dress as a knight
in full battle finery
mount a horse and ride across the city
of south end as he did after receiving a
knighthood
it's this really is unbelievable i'm
making it up
mr speaker seriously thank you for
coming on saturday
to have the prime minister the leader of
the opposition yourself there sent a
real message to the town the city
that the nation cared and the nation was
mourning with us
the impact of david's death has been
profound on the city
southend are in shock and i'm in shock
and i'm told that the pathway going
forward for the city will be difficult
having spoken to people around joe cox's
family i know this is going to be a long
process
we don't want to be the city where the
mp was murdered we want to be the city
with the longest pleasure pier in the
world with a great airport with a
successful football team
even if
even if david was conflicted on the
latter matter as a confirmed man of the
east end and the west ham supporter
he loved his mum who lived to 104.
we all in south and assumed david would
go on forever
the late eric force told me that david
would be the father of the house
i just thought it was going to be thus
one day
but it was not so
in gathering my words i i thought of the
phrase cut short in his prime and then
smirked to myself
given they were somewhat ridiculous age
69 but he was sprightly
he was a secret gym goer a head full of
floppy hair
i just felt that there was more ahead of
him than behind him
sadly his future was stolen from us all
and south end and this house are poorer
for it
over the weekend i kept watching the
news
hoping that the ending of the st story
or news clip would be somehow different
to the previous ending
at a vigil in south end there were
hundreds of people from all walks of
life every story was very different
but at the same time every story was the
same
david listened
david cared
david delivered he had a knack of
getting things done
and has been said i always expected him
to turn up late so i wasn't surprised
when he wasn't at the beginning of the
vigil but i really did expect him to be
there because
he's always there
it's unbelievable he's not coming back
and you think of the last meeting you
had with him i think the last
remembrance day service the last
christmas with him dressing up as santa
claus going out and giving chocolates to
the kids in neptune ward in south end
whether they wanted them or not
[Laughter]
bringing the remainder to my kids who
could stick them to one side and
despite all rules about eating chocolate
but this is not
the last of david he lives on in us all
i don't think david would have seen
himself as a mentor to people in this
house
he wouldn't have called himself that but
that's what he was by demonstration and
osmosis
david inspired great loyalty to his
staff his office was always packed with
people paperwork and as anyone who's
been there with no
fish and birds despite the house
authorities ban on the subject
part office park museum of decades of
political memorabilia part pet shop
it was an office like the politician
unique
he's survived by a lovely family
giulio's wife
his children david junior catherine
sarah alex and florence
and it's with sadness that the family
comes from all corners
to be back together in the city of south
end
we pray for you collectively
their statement yesterday was poignant
they said we ask people to set aside
their differences and show kindness and
love to all
that should not be beyond us all it is
not a bad instruction to this house
let's take that message back to our
constituencies
let's make some good of this horror
and to julia southen thanks your husband
for his service
rest in peace my good friend rest in
peace
can i just say just a real issue with
the house the animals are being looked
after
since we looked up
i would just urge members now to think
of others as we try and get through a
very long list i now come to mother of
the house
mr speaker
thank you mr speaker beyond the horror
we all feel so david's family is first
and foremost in my thoughts
and i want to add my heartfelt sympathy
to his wife and his children their
statement this morning
in their unimaginable shock and grief
shows such extraordinary dignity
sir david was one of the most dedicated
but also the most affable of mps
he looked beyond party differences to
work with so many of us
on a multitude of issues of common
concern and that's why there are tears
on all sides of the house this afternoon
most recently just one example he took
the lead on a cause which i then took up
which was the injustice done to young
unmarried mothers whose babies were
taken from them in the 1960s and 70s
we've all got examples where he's worked
with us
my tribute to him will be to redouble my
efforts on that and to remember and to
work in the spirit that he exemplified
commitment to constituency
commitment to parliament
a belief that he could and did make a
difference
sir david emis rest in peace
now come to the father house so peter
bottom
i agree with harriet and
ian david amos
in 2010
made a speech
where he said it's extraordinary
listening to the acting leader of the
labour party now the mother of the house
he said she made a splendid speech
one of the jokes was fantastic
he's going to use it in the future
david's fire safety all party group
worked with the all-party leasehold and
commonwealth reform group we had a
number of meetings over the year
and as well as the city can i put it to
the prime minister and the chancellor
that they could make his legacy on
defectively sold flats to finding the
fixing and the funding of the problems
while chasing those responsible to pay
up i think he'd wish that
if we looked around this chamber we see
the shields
of those who've died
some in active service in the last world
war ronald clarkland
was the first other members went forward
knowing the risks
so did police constable keith palmer
joe cox and her family are in our hearts
as we've been told and we remember
andrew pennington the liberal mps worker
who also died in a constituency
attack
a few of us were here when erin's car
was blown up
robert bradford and i were together in
the westminster wobblers the house
commons football team tony berry was my
whip
and ian gao and i canvassed together in
ulster
his death
i believe was time to make you forget
the murder of the sister of mercy
catherine dunn
a few days earlier in july 1990.
in david's first speech in january 1984
he said
charity has been described as that
amiable quality that moves us to condone
in others the sins and vices which we
ourselves are addicted to
he was able to say in his first speech
that in the commons
when he made it there were five people
who had previously represented his own
constituency there with him it must be
some kind of a parliamentary record
he was followed by the rightful member
for newcastle qantan east
who cheerfully said at the risk of
dissent from those behind him on the
labour benches i congratulate the old
memphis baswell mr amis on his maiden
speech
i do not agree with what he said but it
was no worse than the speech of the
minister at some risk
ministers of religion
mental health workers
public transport staff
loan shopkeepers
women police officers
journalists
fair employment builders in northern
ireland and the judiciary
and especially women and girls going
home and at home
we should defend people
in every walk of life in politics and
universities
and here i mentioned mildly the
philosopher professor kathleen stock in
my county of
sussex so margaret's church parliament
square where i serve as parliamentary
wardens where we'll gather later today
of the roman catholic service on
wednesday
we've learnt to stand with the irish and
northern irish against violence we stand
with muslims against islamophobia with
jews against anti-semitism and with all
the targets of fascists and white
supremacists
we do have to be vigilant but we also
have to continue to be diligent in
contact with constituents
of course review of your security risks
and i would argue the insecure location
of the national holocaust memorial
presently proposed the victoria tile
gardens
at the opening of the imperial warmest
in polar galleries last week i collected
posters
david might wish us to remember their
words as if directed to us and to our
constituents
freedom is at peril
defend it with all your might
another which brings his face to my mind
your courage your cheerfulness your
resolution will bring us victory and i
end with the words from the prime
minister's first speech to the house of
commons on the 13th of may 1940
let us go forward together
the grief uh the sadness and the shock
we're all feeling today on the awful
loss of sir david amos
this collective sorrow unites us all
today
and likely leave the opposition i want
to reach across the aisle
and say to every conservative colleague
who knew david much better than many of
us on these benches has been so evident
in the brilliant speeches we've heard
we feel for you
david's wonderful friendliness and his
eclectic mix of campaigns that bridge
the political divide were very special
from his campaigns on animal welfare
to his champion of the fuel poor
david always spoke with compassion
authority and often humor
since friday i've spoken to a range of
people
about david
not least liberal democrat councillors
from south end
i have to confess to colleagues opposite
that not all liberal democrat
councillors
are always complimentary
about their sitting conservative mp
but about david amis
their affection
was totally authentic
carol mulroney a counselor in leon c
told me how appreciative she was
of david's support for the lee society
and the local heritage center it runs
local history was clearly a passion of
david's as shown by his champion of the
cause of the endeavour
the only one of lee's little ships
to survive the years since dunkirk
endeavour has been brought back to lee
and restored and now takes part in
dunkirk's ceremonies and local events
not least thanks to david
as well as being proud of southend's
past
david will always be deeply connected to
his present
and its future
not least now we will have the city of
south end
carol told me how david would proudly
boast of walking each road
each street each drive each avenue and
each lane of his constituency
and how supportive he was of every
community
not least the local fishing and cockling
industry
mr speaker
every community
needs champions like david
the point is that we don't have to agree
with each other across our political
divides
but we can learn to be kind and warm
even when we disagree
david was
today is not the day for discussing
implications for mp security and so on
but i do want to reflect on what
happened to one of my close colleagues
from these ventures nearly 21 years ago
yesterday i spoke to nigel jones a
former mp for cheltenham
who many will record a number have
mentioned
was brutally assaulted during
considerably advice surgery
nigel was saved that day by the bravery
of his member of staff
andrew pennington
andrew pennington was killed
andrew was a local councillor who nigel
told me used to work seven days a week
for local residents
he was nigel's right-hand person
so as we reflect on the loss of david
and on the threat to mps let us remember
this too
our staff and many in public services
face abuse
threats
and violence
an alarmingly frequent basis
it's incumbent on us in this house to
defend them all
i'm sure that is what david would have
wanted
to release somebody
thank you mr speaker
laughter
service
compassion
these are three of the words that spring
to my mind when i think of david amos
laughter because you could never have a
conversation with david without laughing
and smiling
uh
whether it was because of one of the
outrageous stories that he was telling
perhaps about one of his colleagues or
somebody else
but there was always smiles always
laughter always fun around david
service because
he
had an extraordinary record of dedicated
service to his constituents and i
suggest anybody who wants to be a
first-class constituency mp that you
look at the example of david amos
he was deeply embedded in his
constituency and as we all know
championed it on every possible occasion
i don't think a question or speech from
david went by in this house without his
constituency being mentioned in it
and but he didn't just promote his
constituency here in the house he was
a part of it he understood it he knew it
he was in the community he was of the
community
and he was respected and loved by the
community
his death is tragic
and the manner of his death appalling
but isn't it fitting that his last acts
were acts of service to his constituents
and then was david's compassion
born out of and strengthened by his
faith
compassion for the vulnerable compassion
for those in need
but he didn't just talk about it he
acted
he changed laws
he went out there and made a difference
to people's lives
because he was also an accomplished
parliamentarian and he knew
that a backbencher who is dedicated and
resolute can make a real difference
and to echo some of the comments that
have been made today
first of all i think it's a wonderful
legacy for david that south end is now a
city
but we can also add to the legacy of
david amos by ensuring that in all our
political debates in our political
discourse
we bring to those debates in that
discourse the same respect decency and
compassion that were the symbols of his
life
because david amos made a difference
his compassion made a difference to
people outside of this house
his kindness made a difference to people
inside this house
our thoughts and prayers
are with julia and the family
their loss is devastating
his constituency has lost
a much respected and loved member of
parliament
this house has lost a remarkable and
valued parliamentarian
and every member of this house
has lost a friend
may he rest in peace
mike king
thank you mr speaker that's been alluded
to sir david was a man of deep catholic
faith
the gospel of john chapter 10 verse 10
reminds us
that the lord came not just to give life
but to give it an abundance
and david lived his life in abundance
a joyous service both to his
constituents
and here in this house we would see him
late at night often in a tuxedo going
from charitable concerns to charitable
concerns
championing
the causes he believed in
he looked good in a tuxedo
no daniel craig but this was no time to
die either
he
he fully
my wife reminded me of the time where we
went to the beatification in rome of
john henry newman just before lockdown
a beautiful service presided over by
pope francis we were whisked to the
oraterian college on one of the
mountains of rome overlooking vatican
city where prince charles addressed us
brilliantly and then the royal cavalcade
went
rushed out
unfortunately the parliamentarians on
the trip were left stranded the former
member for ealing north stephen pound
the former naval commander decided to
lead the vanguard in a military
operation to get us back down to our
hotel like troglodytes we entered this
cave and ended up in this vast
franciscan
monastery our party became separated it
was now more like an healing comedy
under stephen's
leadership my wife reminded me that i
abandoned her her safety to a lifelong
labour activist my wife to three tory
mps getting stuck in a lift including
basel and man she said
because he was still etched on our 1992
election memory the other two mps by the
way were north dawson the filed coast so
i will catch mark and simon up about
what went on in that lift because my
wife said what an utterly utterly uh
wonderful man he participated fully in
the liturgy of the church he
participated fully in the sacraments of
the church
while i have the attention of the front
benches catholics believe that extreme
unction
helps guide the soul to god after death
so maybe we could come up with an amos
amendment no matter where it is in the
care home or a crime scene that members
anybody maybe can receive that sacrament
he believed fundamentally in the social
teaching of the church dignity
solidarity subsidiarity to the nth
degree when it came to south end um
preferential option for
poor and the care for environment that
came meant he came with unique views on
things such as life death
europe animal protection
sometimes in china this party sometimes
in china with the country but sometimes
not he channeled the 14th century mystic
the julian of norwich she said all
things shall be well and all manner of
things shall be well that's difficult
for us all here today his cheeky catch
phrase was don't worry it will be fine
not quite bruce forsyth but he was a
friend of bruce forsyths and his family
um he did not die a martyr but he died
as being said by doing the things he
loved helping constituents he would have
known the theologian carl rayner would
have said that power was a gift from god
that port cullet on the top of our
letterheads gives us all that power
whether on the front bench or whether in
opposition or whether on the back
benches let's recommit to sir david
today that we will use that power for
the common good he died
on the feast of centuries revealia and
she said this famously
trust god that you are exactly where you
are meant to be
may you not forget the infinite
possibilities that are born of faith
many of you use those gifts that you
have received and pass on the love that
has been given to you
david used those gifts
and he passed on that love
so sir david
may the choirs of angels come to greet
you
may they lead you to paradise
may the lord enfold you in his mercy
may he grant you eternal life
eternal rest give to him o lord
and let perpetual light shine upon him
may his soul and the souls of all the
faithful departed through the mercy of
god
rest in peace
andrew rottenday
uh mr speaker um
it was a true privilege
to have known david amos
he was simply
one of the best people i've ever known
in my entire life
he was a true friend
he had time for each and every one of us
he
looked down on no one he was everyone's
equal
he was kind
he was generous
he was sincere
he was a man of principle and courage
he was uncompromising
in what he believed to be right
he wasn't one of these who
changed his views in order to progress
he knew what he believed in
and he stood firm for those things
he was a man of enormous integrity
but he was a true friend to so many of
us i knew him
for around 40 years
we became friends instantly because we
shared the same political views
but we came from the same background
i am from essex
some say east london but i say essex
and he knew he knew
that our instincts coming from that neck
of the woods were the same and we hit it
off from day one
we were committed to this country we
love our country he was a passionate
believer in britain a true patriot
he was a royalist
he was never
afraid to fly the flag
and to champion great british values
he was a christian and was proud to be a
christian and uphold the christian
heritage of this country
he also loved animals
as i do
and he almost loved my dogs as much i
loved his dogs and many occasions
visiting his home in south end often
taking my own elderly mother and he had
an elderly mother who lived till 104 and
when his mum died he
he spoke to my mother as if it was his
mother he treated me like family
and
my heart goes out to julia and the the
five children who are wonderful people
he he he had a fantastic family
and he was so dedicated so dedicated to
his constituencies basildon and southend
west he lived for them and he did
sacrifice
everything else to put his constituency
first
and i will say this mr speaker the one
legacy
the one legacy must hold to true to
david is not to let his horrific
murder
the horrific way that he left us
to change
our democracy
i remember the day after the
the appalling
grand hotel bombing
in brighton in 1984
and i remember margaret thatcher and he
was a dedicated supporter of margaret
thatcher i remember her saying it's
business as usual
we must help carry on
and i take the same view whatever
happens
whatever we do to to to carry on and
protect ourselves we must not let our
democracy be undermined by that kind of
evil we must stand up to evil defend our
democracy cherish the freedom
that give gives all of us the right to
be here and represent our constituents
and defend and cherish the freedoms and
the liberties
that have held our country together for
generations david was a fine example of
a parliamentarian
a magnificent constituency mp
a true friend
a gentleman
a truly wonderful human being we're
going to miss him
but i feel truly privileged
to have known him
thank you david
god bless you
so jeffrey donald
thank you mr speaker on behalf of the my
right honourable and honorable friends i
rise to record uh the common and unified
voice of the people of northern ireland
who share in the grief and sorrow at the
loss of our esteemed and much loved
colleague and friend and my
condolences and sympathy to you prime
minister and to your colleagues on the
conservative benches
words cannot adequately describe nor
suitably express our heartfelt sympathy
but through the words that have been
spoken here today and across our nation
in recent days i pray that they sustain
and give strength to david's family
no one will feel the loss of david more
than his family
to his wife julia his beloved children
and to the wider family circle on behalf
of my party i offer my heartfelt
condolences and deepest sympathy
and trust and pray that almighty god the
greatest of all comforters will draw
near to all of them
david epitomized the true meaning of
public service
he was the model parliamentarian
he sought office not for self
but to serve others
influenced by his deep christian faith
to champion the needs of the most
vulnerable
to give a voice to the voiceless and to
stand up for the interests of the people
of south and west
david's greatest joy came not in holding
office
but in how he could use that office to
improve the everyday lives of those he
was honored to represent
the people of his constituency and now
to
and from the city of south end have lost
their greatest champion
and i mr speaker like members on all
sides of this house
have lost a dear friend
the plaques at the entrance door to this
chamber and around this chamber in
memory of the late erie neve
robert bradford
anthony berry ian gow
and duke hawkes
are a daily reminder to all of us of the
threat our democracy faces
in modern times
in northern ireland
all parties in this chamber have
experienced these threats
and the loss of dear colleagues at the
hands of the enemies of democracy
today this house sends a clear message
a resounding message the democracy in
the united kingdom will never be
suppressed
our voices will never fall silent
and we will never allow triumph evil to
triumph over good
david taught us all the true meaning of
public service
he showed us
the true value of public office
and provided us all
with a true example of faith in public
life
his legacy lives on in all those causes
and communities he championed
in the lives he improved
and in all those he inspired
mr speaker it now falls upon us all to
take forward the beacon of hope
along the path that david led us and to
ensure that the flame of his legacy is
never extinguished
this house is the poorer for his loss
and this country
all of it
mourns the tragic passing of one of its
most faithful servants
our response collectively to this is
simple
when one of us falls
another will step forward
together we will continue
to defend the values and ideals that
david stood for
and that are the foundation stones
of this great nation
thank you
we now come to jackie doyle price
thank you
mr speaker i think the whole house will
be left in uh no doubt of the genuine
affection that sir davis constituents
held him
just by watching the tv footage uh this
weekend and
uh as a friend of his i'm hugely
comforted by the genuine affection
that's been shown uh today and and in
response by honourable members
um you know for me david was a great
friend as well as a great
parliamentarian
now last week uh sir david led a
delegation
of the all party group on a visit to
qatar and he led that delegation with
his characteristic good humor may i say
great fun
and inclusivity and during the course of
that visit we had the
benefits of an audience with his
highness the emea
and as the meeting came to close
david with great flourish referred to
the need to present a gift
and with his characteristic
self-deprecation he said what could i
give the man who has everything here is
the inscribed copy of my book
who haven't yet read david's book can i
suggest you go out and get a copy
because the proceeds go to some of the
charities that he championed yeah um
and could also say that in actual fact
uh if you read the book it is the
authentic voice of david with his pen
portraits some of which are humorous
some of which are quite barbed
um but it but it is actually a great
insight into parliament from somebody
who as we've heard today spent much of
his career on all of his career on the
back benches but he loved this place he
he genuinely thought it was a privilege
to be a member of parliament he loved
his work on the panel of chairs
he was proud of the legislation that he
secured
end of term adjournment debates they
will never ever be the same again will
they
and he may yet have become father of the
house
but what i want i believe to the serious
point here is that in the 38 years he
served as a member of parliament one of
the things he lamented
was the decline in respect for this
institution and for the members within
it and the reason he laments it was
because he felt our constituents were
the poorer for it
because as that respect declined and we
just became inconveniences to be managed
by public authorities rather than the
genuine voice of challenge and i think
if we do anything uh to remember him
that is something he would wish us to
collectively work to address as that
what may is what makes this place uh
worth while
we must in reflecting on his memory not
remember the way in which his life was
taken but remember how he lived
and his beaming face in 1992 when his
victory marked a fourth election victory
of the conservatives is of course iconic
but i should say to the house his
biggest pride was actually not that
result but the one in 1983 when he won
basildon for the first time a victory
which is against the odds as much as the
one in 1992
and i would say that he held basildon
as a marginal seat for all that time
because he was an amazing campaigner he
had time for everyone as we've heard
before
his megaphone was never too far away and
i have to say we enjoyed some visits
with david his megaphone in floric over
the years and always great fun
but as an eastender he instinctively
represented the politics of south asics
he would describe himself as a working
class conservative and very much
epitomised the kind of person who
embraced the politics of margaret
thatcher and
he would recruit with great pride at the
occasion when after everyone had written
his election prospects off in 1992 it
was margaret thatcher who came on the
eve of poll to to support him and uh he
credited that with with party's victory
our thoughts are obviously now with sir
david's family and i just a final note
just just say that the last time i went
to dave's house he was proudly showing
me his wedding video
and the reason he was doing so was not
just to show me the honourable member
for derbyshire dales and her dancing
back in in those days in 1983 and he was
hugely proud that she got here too but
actually the exact wedding that he had
to julia in 1983 with westminster
cathedral and then a reception here was
what he repeated for his daughter only a
few weeks ago
and uh i hope the whole family uh
received some comfort from the fact that
we all loved him yeah yeah john cryer
thank you mr speaker um i knew david for
perhaps 25
years and for eight years we were
constituency neighbours when i was the
mp for
horn church and following on from one of
the anecdotes given by the honourable
member for rayleigh and and and wickford
i remember
david telling me a few times that there
were a number of times when people would
say on the doorstep particularly in
basildon
i'm going to vote for you david because
you're a good labour man
i know i once said to him did you ever
put him right david
he said
uh
that was the closest i got to an answer
so i think we can all deduce from that
that he probably didn't and put them put
them right we all know i think we all
know that david was a hyper con high
presiduous
constituency mp
and the only one member for thor
mentioned this the pre-recess the german
debates and david and i were
for a long time both contributors to
every seemed like every pre-recess the
german debate uh we used to call it
whinging gets day and for those of you
who've taken part those members who've
taken part in those debates
they can all probably imagine why david
and i would have called it whinjin gets
there and it used to be a bit of a
competition to see who could get in
the number of mat the greatest number of
constituency topics into the debate i
don't think i ever won i think david won
every time every debate i was in
he won with eight nine ten issues that
he would cover in that sort of staccato
way that he had um i just want to say
one more thing um about david
and that is that um
on perhaps a more general point
there are profound and visceral issues
that divide parties in this place
and individuals
but they are minuscule compared to what
divides us from the forces of darkness
who brought this about yeah and just to
say one more thing on a and this is a
deeply personal note and this is on
behalf of my wife ellie and and i who's
here
and that is that one thing i will always
remember about david
is that he would always ask about our
sons about our children and how they
were
they were getting on and that is
something i will carry for the rest of
my life
sharia smith
i apologize mr speaker um i'm going to
be or i intend to be brief
um
[Laughter]
after all pretty much everything about
david has been said but that doesn't
mean i can't repeat it um can i just say
uh david i knew him for 29 years when i
first came in in 1992
he was outstandingly and unfailingly
kind
conscientious and generous even to new
members had arrived
eight years after him and i remember
very clearly i also uh remember later on
when i got to know him better uh
recalling that uh somebody in my
constituency has referred to david when
he was in basil dinners somebody that
went
always to the opening of an envelope so
i put this to him i said you are accused
of going to the opening of an envelope
and he said i damn well hope so because
i wrote it to them so i could go there
in the first place
i also remember
i also remember
when uh when they won basildon council i
think uh for the first time he was there
not enough for david was it to um
to just
be with them when they went in
uh he formed a conga outside the chamber
and took the whole of the newly elected
councils on a conga right the way
through the council buildings and into
the chamber his sense of humor mr
speaker was always there and it was
always preceded by this megawatt smile
that he could turn on like that for most
of us here in this chamber it's hard
work sometimes to be able to smile
enough but for david it was hard work
not to smile and he would smile even in
some of the most difficult circumstances
we already know by the way when i um
when i ceased being leader i say with
some respect to the honorable no matter
how much he's enjoying it now it's
really not cracked what it's cracked up
to be i'd have to tell it
[Laughter]
that's what i thought too um
i i simply say that well i had to go and
speak at an event for him and uh he
patted me on the shoulder and said are
you going all right i said yeah it's
fine fine fine uh and he got up and
introduced me by saying uh i'm so
pleased to have you in dr smith here
he's just slid down the greasy pole and
then he carried on so
he did follow that by telling me
directly afterwards that he had
retired finally from a long time
in government
and he thought he would have more
influence elsewhere he actually spent a
very short time in government but that
didn't bother him in the slightest bit
i want to say mr speaker that on a more
serious note that david has shown us the
way
the way of cooperation
and i know for a fact that many well
most members in this place
know that you get things done by
cooperating across this floor
in fact very little has talked about
that mr speaker as you know but it is in
fact the embodiment of exactly who we
are in this place
we cannot get stuff done by ourselves so
we form alliances whether it's on modern
day slavery whether it's in my case on
gambling harms you know you go on you
form these alliances and then you
eventually move things and you get them
done but he was the architect of this
there wasn't an alliance that he
couldn't form even if there wasn't an
issue on which he could form it he would
form it and the point about this mr
speaker as i say this is who we are
we are often as joe cox said
more united by the things we believe in
than necessarily divided the fact is
that
we are in this place
because we argue with each other about
our ideas
the important feature with this is we
may disagree with our arguments
but we don't
disrespect the motives of those who hold
them and we need to be very careful this
is a lesson to us
that we need to be careful here what we
legitimize in what we say about our
colleagues
they are not evil people nobody in this
chamber is an evil individual they have
strong beliefs i'm struck when the media
reported uh that you know they'd
finished talking about him and then they
said and he was a man with very strong
held beliefs as though this was an aside
that they wanted to bury somewhere else
we come here because we have strong
beliefs and we should be proud of that
we argue with each other because we are
the point where people can see us debate
these things have power of emotion be
angry about them because this place is a
cockpit of that so they don't have to do
it outside violently elsewhere
but we need to show
publicly mr speaker i believe is what
the point he was making
is that
we need to show each other the respect
that those ideas are greatly held
we respect each other but we don't
dislike or hate each other that is not
for us and it is not for that that he in
fact lost his life in fact today through
the door of my constituency office mr
speaker i've been told that there is in
fact a document that came through the
front page all about him and on it it
had like you
you bastard
in fact i did think he might have done
it because it was spelt
e b-i-r-s-t-e-d mr speaker so i think
even in that threat there is a sense of
irony i want to say mr speaker in
conclusion
that his family this is a tragedy
which is deranged hateful and violent
individual has brought to them
unwarranted and without cause
and david taught us something very
important that they can remember that he
believed in the power not the power of
position
but the power of purpose
mr speaker
they told us heraclitus they told us you
were dead they brought me bitter tears
to hear and bitter tears to shed
i thought as i was crying how often you
and i had tired the sun with talking and
sent him down the sky
and now that thou are lying a pile of
great ashes long long ago dead
thy nightingales
by voices
are awake
and that is the important thing mr
speaker he will be with us forever
can i just uh just be trying to be brief
to get plenty of others in
vector
thank you mr speaker i'll just join
briefly the tributes that we have heard
because sir david amis asked all of us
about our families and
probably we send our condolences now to
his family not just from all of us but
from all of our families too who will be
feeling very much the need to reach out
to them at this difficult time we pay
tribute to to
sir david's staff who just went to work
on friday morning just like all of our
staff do
going to try and help his constituents
like every one of our constituents and
had to face the unimaginable on friday
morning
every one of us has a story of things
that we worked with david on so many
different issues for me
it was the work we did together on
amendments to help child refugees
reunite with their families something he
felt strongly about and you could never
predict what the issue was going to be
he would feel strongly about next but
then you look back on it and think it
made absolute sense
that this was what he was championing
because so often
kindness and compassion were at the
heart of it and helping others too
he was his office is just above mine
so very often it just chat to him
walking to the votes coming across here
and really felt it just walking across
here now to come and pay tribute to him
and knowing i wouldn't walk across here
with him again chatting about our
families
but you could never get wrong which
floor you were on coming out of the lift
for david's office
because as many of you will know there
is hanging on his door
a giant cardboard cutout of a knight in
shining armor
with the helmet tilted in a jaunty way
just looking at you and that knight in
shining armor is what david would have
been to so many of his constituents
around the corner there is a box with
the um
nodding reindeer decorations in just
ready to be spread across the corridors
because that was what david would do at
christmas time would be just spreading
joy and spreading a bit of friendship
and a bit of joy and if you stand there
by that night today you will also my
deputy speaker i confess hear the
ethereal sound of birdsong
as well
for so many reasons
um for david and
i think the for all of us look joe
said to us we have more in common than
that which divides us
david showed us how to do that
because whilst he had disagreements with
pretty much every one of us he also had
the unerring instinct of finding what it
was he had in common with each and every
one of us as well
and so when we face awful things
happening when we know that extremists
try to divide us we know that the most
powerful thing that we have in our
defense in our armory against them and
in defense of democracy is the powerful
words said on all sides of the house in
unity in defense of democracy but also
in respect for david now
john whittingdale
i first met david amis nearly 40 years
ago um shortly after his historic
election as mp for basildon um the image
of which the picture of his smiling face
came to symbolize the conservative
victory under margaret thatcher's
leadership
he won
because he embodied all that was best
about essex man
he was patriotic he came from a working
class background
he was devoted to his family
he was passionately independent
i got to know him when i was working for
margaret thatcher in 10 downing street
he adored her he was absolutely furious
when she was removed from office and
indeed remained furious
[Laughter]
and in 2013 he held an adjournment
debate on her legacy uh following her
death
she in turn hugely valued him
david championed many courses as others
have said but most of all he loved his
constituency
and the people that he was so proud to
represent
my constituency is just about 30 minutes
away from his and a number of times i
spoke for him at events and he spoke for
me and the huge respect and affection in
which he was held was always obvious
he loved meeting people and he made sure
that he spoke to every single person at
whatever gathering he was present
this is being referred it became a joke
that for his first 14 years he would
make sure that in every question
or in every speech he referenced
basildon in ringing tones as my
honourable friend uh demonstrated in his
contribution and then after his election
for south end his campaign for southend
to become a city again was mentioned at
every opportunity
it's well known that he was a great
animal lover and devoted to his dogs
and even when seeking support
for his french dog
vivian
in this year's westminster dog of the
year competition as the prime minister
referenced the reason he gave
as to why we should vote for vivian as
westminster dog of the year
was that she is an enthusiastic
supporter of south end becoming an
assistant
[Laughter]
so when in 2012
chelmsford as the county town of essex
was granted city status
david took the news reasonably well
i can say on behalf of my constituents
in chelmsford
how delighted we are that essex now has
two cities
i represent a part of the chelmsford
local authority area but my honourable
friend the member for chelmsford has the
city itself she's unable to be here
today as she's on ministerial duties
abroad but she asked me to say on her
behalf how much she appreciated the
kindness
and gentle wisdom that david typically
showed to her and other new essex mps
when they were first elected
i also join in her in paying tribute to
the work that david did
for all of us
to improve our hospitals across mid and
south essex a legacy that will continue
to benefit hundreds of thousands of
david of essex residents
david was quite simply
the best of us
all of us are still in shock
but our hearts go out to his family
and i hope the people listen
to their words
my honourable friend for rayleigh
spoke powerfully about the abuse that
people particularly members of
parliament and not just mps a lot of
other public servants suffer from on
online social media
i've been heartened by the huge number
of messages that i've had
from my constituents and from others
firstly to express condolences and
secondly just to express their
appreciation of the work that we do in
this place and i like to think and i
strongly believe that
those
horrible aggressive voices that
sometimes seem to dominate social media
are not representative of the views of
the vast majority of people who share
all the qualities and and would respond
to the appeal of david's family that we
should show each other kindness and love
and that should be his lasting legacy
stephen timms
thank you madam deputy speaker
we've we've rightly been reminded of
david's enthusiastic advocacy
for uh the the constituencies that he
represented but he was also an
enthusiast for the london borough of
newark where he was born and grew up
where he attended the excellent saint
bonaventures catholic school which he
stayed in touch with for the rest of his
life where he supported west ham united
football club um and where his mother
lived until her death as we've been
reminded at the age of 104 five years
ago i heard over the weekend from
somebody who was in the sixth form
accent bonaventures with
david but unlike david supported the
labour party
and he told me that the politics teacher
mr cunningham predicted that david was
going to be
a conservative mp
but he also told me that in a period
when he wasn't able to attend quite a
lot of the politics
lessons david very carefully wrote out
all of his notes so that his friend
could copy those notes afterwards
kindness was evident at that early stage
as well david stood for election to the
council in newham in 1974 and 1978 and
for parliament
in new and northwest in 1979 before
finding more promising opportunities
further east
but notwithstanding party differences
his supportive interest in new and
remained as council leader from 1990 i
pressed the conservative government to
bring the channel tunnel rail link
through a station in stratford david was
our unwavering ally on the government
side he made
single-handedly he made the campaign
cross-party and that was crucial to its
success leading to london 2012
to the regeneration that's underway at
the moment of course david was not
initially seen as a friend by my newham
council colleagues
who haven't seen a conservative uh
elected for 30 years
we all remembered david
dashing our 1992 general election hopes
by holding basildon
but we invited him to our town hall
celebration when the stratford campaign
succeeded i wasn't quite sure how that
was going to go
but david won over everybody with a
beautifully judged speech newham has
lost a great friend
he was accessible to his constituents
tragically he has now given his life we
will rightly reflect on what more we can
do to stop that happening again i wonder
if we might ask the police to review our
appointment lists ahead of each surgery
for example
but we mustn't give up on the
accessibility of members of parliament
if we do
the opponent the sponsors of those who
attacked david
and who attacked me will have succeeded
that must not happen
we would all like to have a long time to
hear more of these heartwarming
stories and recollections of our dear
lost friend but we are due to go to
church quite soon so i implore
colleagues please just take two minutes
or so each because then everyone will
get a chance to say what they would like
to say
sir roger gail
thank you madam deputy speaker we've
heard magnificent tributes from the
prime minister from the leader of the
opposition
from david's essex colleagues
and from many on the opposition benches
as well and
i think we are all grateful for that and
the tone of the house is as the house
can be at its best
i want to speak just a couple of minutes
speaking on behalf of the remnants of
the class of 83.
we came in
100 of us
in 1983.
now there are
sadly
only two
remaining with continuous service and
another three
who have come back having left the house
briefly
we had all hoped and expected
that in the fullness of time
once my right honourable friend the
member for worthing has surrendered his
position
by which time of course david would have
been a very old man
we had hoped that he would become the
father of the house
because he would have made a magnificent
successor to my righteous friend
sadly and cruelly
that has been denied
those of us
many on both sides of the house who
worked with david's on his campaigns
i had that privilege whether that was on
fox hunting when it was unfashionable to
do so
whether it was
on
the reunification of cyprus or iran
or pensions for expat uk citizens or a
whole range of other issues
know just what a doubting campaigner he
was
that clearly is why he was so loved in
his constituency madam deputy speaker
the speaker said at the weekend
that david's death had left a void in
this house of course he was absolutely
right
there is another void
in david's family home
i hope that
david's wife julia
and his children will take comfort
from the fact that across this house
there is clearly nothing
but affection
for his memory
and that must speak volumes
for the man whose life we celebrate
today
kim ledbetter
thank you madam deputy speaker
i've spent a lot of time over the
weekend um thinking about what to say if
i got called today
or indeed whether to say anything at all
because i didn't know david personally
it's been a traumatic few days for many
people
none more so than david's family and
friends and it's there who remain at the
forefront of my mind this afternoon
but sadly i know from my own all too
similar experience
that in reality there is nothing anyone
can say to make things all right for
them
but nor is it any use to stay silent
so i welcome this opportunity to pay
tribute to someone who was clearly a
well-respected and much-loved colleague
to many people in this place
for reasons that i would never wish on
any other member of this house or indeed
anyone
i do have a unique perspective on what
those closest to david are going through
and i want to send them my love support
and solidarity
from myself my parents our family and
the people of valley and spain
i've blocked out much of what happened
when joe was murdered
but i remember very clearly the moment i
took the phone call saying she had been
attacked
i remember physically trembling
and the visceral pain that overtook me
and it breaks my heart to think that
another family has had to experience
that phone call
and the nightmare which follows
is a rollercoaster of deep trauma that
no one should have to
experience i also know that david's
family will still be in utter shock
as i know many of you are
but i hope at some point they are able
to hear at least some of the beautiful
and very funny tributes that have been
paid to him today
and that that will provide a mortal of
comfort amidst their pain
i can't talk about david on a personal
level as i say i didn't know him
but from what i've heard he strikes me
as the sort of mp who i may well have
come across in the coming months and
ended up going for a couple with him to
hear his thoughts on the work he was
doing on the children's parliament or
animal welfare or getting more support
for people with learning disabilities
we would have been two back bench mps
from different parties and different
parts of the country discussing issues
close to our hearts
and i imagine it would have been a lot
of
fun but sadly that day will never come
i know that wider discussions will now
take place about the safety of mps
the awful abuse and intimidation we face
the nature of political discourse
and how we can deal with the evils of
terrorism
and it's quite right that they do
but today is about david and his family
along with his staff
colleagues and the community he served
so well the service he gave
and the support we should show all of
them in the coming days weeks and months
it is up to us to make sure that we do
because i know more than most that they
will need it
and the powerful difference it will make
to them
so david thank you very much deputy
speaker and david was indeed a great
character with a fantastic sense of
humor and i'm honored to be able to call
him my friend
so much has already been said about him
that i don't want to do repetition but
we were both elected to parliament for
the first time in 1983 with small
majorities and became firm friends
during the 1980s and shared an office
together until 87 in the abbey gardens
we shared staff also for a while and in
those days the commons sat very late and
i was fortunate to get to know david
really well during this time his
cheerfulness and dedication were his
hallmarks throughout his parliamentary
career
his boundless energy well many of us
couldn't keep up
and when he took us canvassing and
campaigning in pasadena we certainly
couldn't keep up
working together in the office however
with david was quite an experience
as we've already heard the uh
the uh
menagerie of things that were in his
office
but david also was never backward in
coming forward i remember going on the
first occasion to a number 10 reception
after we've been elected and of course i
was all in awe of every prime minister
including the government of course
[Laughter]
margaret thatcher was the prime minister
and of course ah she said i can't do her
accent but she put a head on one side
the two davids
and i just said promise and lovely to be
here and all the rest of it and uh david
amen said well i've never been here
before can you do me a tour
at that moment i wish
i had quietly died
but she said yes i'll come and get you
later
and she did
we had to tour it and she said ah but
i'm gonna take you upstairs to the flat
and show you upstairs and she said this
is where of course i cooked dennis's
breakfast
really said he has cooked breakfast yes
she said well it's really pokey up here
he didn't think much of it so
so he never had aspirations to be prime
minister i think
or if he did
anyway
he was a friend i was privileged to know
him privileged to work with him on so
many campaigns he was a great
parliamentarian a great politician a
fantastic advocate on behalf of his
constituents and a great champion of our
nation
he was also one of the nicest kindest
and most genuine people i've ever met
always smiling and was an interfatical
campaigner for all the many issues that
he held dear
we're all devastated by his murder and
i'm privileged to know his wife and
family over the years and we think of
them and we grieve with them
but we will remember his legacy
and we will look on the positive side
because one thing david amos always was
was very positive yeah
and i'm proud to have known him thank
you
[Music]
thank you madam deputy speaker if you
had told me before i was elected in 2015
that just a few years later i'd be
sitting at home greeting over the death
of a thatch right tory mp i would not
have believed you but my partner nady
and i did just that for it was david who
had died
david was the first cross-party friend i
made in the commons when i was elected
he was a joy to work with on committee
and he wrote me into all sorts of apgs
and escapades as well
and he will be solely missed he will not
however be forgotten
and when i think back in my memories in
this place most favorite ones will
feature david he already i should say
features in a number of my burned upper
speeches around the story of a haggis
but that's too long to tell in these
short tributes and i hope i can find the
energy and the enthusiasm to tell it
with the fun that it deserves so let me
just pay my respects to david and send
my best wishes to his family i cannot
believe what they will be going through
at this time
thank you
so graeme brady thank you madam deputy
speaker i'll be brief because i know
there are many others who still want to
pay their respects and their i give
their tributes um
as a dedicated and effective back bench
member of parliament it's right that i
should
pay tribute as chairman of the 1922
committee but i wanted to say a few
words today because i've like so many
others have the privilege of his
friendship uh for the last uh 24 years
and i'm deeply touched by the tributes
that have been paid across the house
moving tributes from the prime minister
and from the league of the opposition
i'm pleased to follow my friend the
chairman of the parliamentary labour
party
my neighbour from within toronto who's
one of the first on friday to get in
touch with me for his condolences which
is much appreciated and
i think we all
have had so many
messages
of condolence
from constituents and others since that
terrible news
on friday i think people across the
country
could sense
the goodness the kindness the decency of
the man that we have
lost and i think it's wonderful we've
had tributes to the great achievements
that david uh had in politics it's also
wonderful we've had so many references
right from the start
to the joy uh that david brought into
all our lives and into so many uh other
lives
too
he clearly enjoyed
the house of commons he enjoyed politics
he loved meeting people and uh i hope
that is something that will stay with us
uh i just say uh finally my recollection
always uh over the last few years
especially i'd see him in port culley's
house he'd see me going the other way
the infectious smile
would begin and you knew that he was
looking forward to starting the
conversation what are they doing now
graham uh he'd say um
why why are they doing this um
and uh and i will miss that uh like
others i will still be looking out for
him uh and the final thing uh that i
wanted to say if you like the serious
point uh is that this is the most open
and accessible uh parliament of any
major country in the world
and the right tribute to david must be
that it remains said that we
we will take sensible uh precautions but
we will keep open and we will continue
to connect with our constituents as he
did
sarah dimes
thank you madam deputy speaker it is
with incredible sadness and i have to
admit some anger that i rise to pay
tribute to my friend david today
i was fortunate enough to have known
david before he entered this house as a
friend a family friend and some three
decades later as a parliamentary
colleague
my mother elizabeth was his association
chairman and at times election agent in
basildon before during and after the
1983 election he was of course mp for
basel and as well as south end from
basildon from 1983 until 97 when i made
my maiden speech last year like many
other members who came new to this house
he was there
he was seated just behind me his face
beamed with delight when i recalled as a
teenager when i'd been the yc
representative on his committee that
selected him to become the prospective
conservative candidate for basildon in
1983.
i remember then not now that young that
very enthusiastic candidate a very good
looking unconfirmed bachelor
with a flowing new romantic hairstyle
he fought a very energetic election
campaign in 83 with a very very small
team of helpers we all had our jobs i
made cups of tea i was 16 or 17 at the
time we came back after a hard day's
canvassing my father tony often had to
go and find him he'd be talking to
somebody or more often he would just
have run out of petrol that was david
david was of course briefly i'll just go
on a
recipient of constant motherly advice
from my mother who was his chairman it
was don't worry of course you're going
to win
you'd better get married now david
and you need to have some children right
through to you'd better get a haircut
of course he did win basildon he married
the love of his life julia and the
children followed one after another in
rapid succession but he never did get
that haircut
i know david as a showman i could tell
you numerous stories i've had to throw
most of the best ones away but what i
will say is that when i found myself on
these benches following the last
election
he was delighted
he went out of his way to settle me in
into the institution he loved so much
and i know that he meant it many others
not just me and i speak on behalf of all
of the 2019 intake and say how very sad
we are to lose him
let's shovel roberts
and it is an honor to write to speak on
behalf of my my party and to send
commiserations to sir david's family and
friends and colleagues and i think the
one thing that i would really like to
emphasize i think for people outside
do not actually appreciate possibly how
much we work together and how much of an
honor it is to work together and how we
by that achieve so much
and it's the one other thing that i
would like to say i think for all of us
here
just the reality of what democracy
actually is
democracy is what we have developed as
the means that we do not no longer
attack each other and use violence to
achieve our aims
and when we see this terrible abhorrent
death which has struck us so badly and
struck of course the constituents and so
many people who knew sir david so well
it has struck us so hardly that we
remember that when we stand up for
democracy we are standing up for that
for civility
and for good behavior and for treating
people properly because historically the
alternative has been violence
and violence must never be allowed to
succeed again
thank you mr speaker i rise to pay
respects to our dear colleague and my
friend sir david amos
i got to know david from
2017 when he reached out to me with that
characteristic kindness he had an
extraordinary gift of knowing what to
say as well as when to say it his many
kindnesses provided a firm foundation
for our work together on the dame vera
memorial project
he was a christian soul a fellow
catholic and his life fully reflected
his beliefs
he also enjoyed life he loved people and
had that lightness of avacity and
enthusiasm that drew people to him and
was infectious
for so many months we have been working
together on the dain vera memorial foot
the white cliffs of dover he spearheaded
this project
from the very beginning
from similar working-class backgrounds
we shared a commitment to creating
opportunity and social mobility so it
made sense that the dame vera project is
the centerpiece of our leveling up fund
bid for dover one that brings together
opportunity jobs culture and
entertainment
for as the house knows
david was a great entertainer as well as
campaigner
my enduring memories of david
will be
both of us
arm-in-arm around the piano singing
today in vera's songs
him taking selfies at the white cliffs
of dover
the dane vera project was very close to
david's heart
sir david's family have made a call for
public support for the daimvira
fundraising in his memory so let's get
behind that and get the fundraising done
build the memorial and include in it a
tribute to the life of sir david amos a
lovely man who was a true friend to me a
friend to dover and to our nation
thank you mr speaker
i want to join the tribute to the
honourable member for south and west who
was a kind and generous colleague in the
house and a committed and conscientious
constituency
just how conscientious he was can be
seen in his record of speaking an action
in the house
i had a recollection of him
speaking in a pre-recess adjournment
debate back in 2009 when i was deputy
leader of the house and it was my job to
respond to that debate and a couple of
of the speeches earlier we've heard
about these uh sir david's performance
of these debates
i remember that sir david had raised
many many points that day to be answered
or sent for action in departments so i
look back at the three christmas recess
adjournment debate in december 2009
i found this amazing list of matters
which sir david raised with me
he's fewer than labour government the
state of the economy small shops having
visited every small shop in his
constituency in the summer recess the
pay of public servants and the scrutiny
of public sector pay
communications with his chief constable
and decision-making structures in the
police our forces serving in afghanistan
the chill cut inquiry solvent abuse
vioxx and compensation for uk users of
it tax credits and the tax credits
helpline the south end association of
voluntary services and funding for them
services for people with rheumatoid
arthritis seat belts and the risks of
people not wearing them
and he concluded as it was the
pre-christmas uh a german debate this
impressive list by talking about the
issues of unwanted pets at christmas and
the work of the international fund for
animal welfare i have to say to my
honourable friend the member for
leighton and onested that was 15 issues
the reason he beat you in these debates
is it wasn't eight nine or ten and
that's why he won
[Laughter]
i
fast forwarded to the most recent
pre-recess adjournment debate on 26th of
july this year just to see if it was a
similarly impressive list and it was
care costs both of self-payers and
council-funded costs the accessibility
of housing for people with a disability
use of tidal power the safety of jet
skis single-use plastics sewage
discharge from storm overflows planting
of trees in south end for the queen's
platinum jubilee banning live export of
animals for slaughter the pension
ombudsman approaches to working with
vulnerable children the public appeal
for a permanent memorial in dover today
in viral lin which he helped to launch
good wishes for olympic and paralympic
athletes praised for a constituent who
had done a wing walk for charity
centenary of the british legion and as
ever mr speaker a plea to make south
hender city
how wonderful that his strongest
campaign for city status at south end
will happen the city he loved and thanks
to her majesty for approving that
mr speaker i'll finish by saying this
there were so many causes that sir david
championed and so many of us were
cross-party with him on issues such as
support for people with endometriosis
there was going to be a debate on that
today and children with learning
disability
david's family have asked us to renew
our commitment to the many causes he
championed
it is a heartwarming tribute to david's
work that south end will become a city
we will continue that tribute by
renewing and carrying on the work he
started
not mentioned
mr speaker may i begin by giving my
condolences and prayers to his wife
julia and his five children mr speaker
not only did savage represent the people
of south end west and was a dedicated
campaigner on a broad range of issues
achieving some real meaningful changes
he also spent a great deal of time
representing this house and overseas
delegations and this is what i want to
focus on this afternoon
so david was an active member of the ipu
the cpa and a number of appg's including
the appg for the holy see and it was on
delegations like this that i first got
to know so david well
it's a well documented that said david
was a devout catholic but even in the
hallowed walls of the vatican so david
did not lose his mischievous sense of
humor
i think of a time when we're in the
vatican for the canonization of cardinal
newman which has already been referred
to
and we attended a high broad theological
seminar with cardinals midway through
david whispered to me
isn't this fabulous i can see you're
loving it to which she replied to be
honest not really david i'm not really
understanding it
and it was at the tea break that david
and i slipped out like erin's schoolboys
i said to him david are we not getting
into trouble walking through the vatican
gardens said nah
and no no we did
but out of the way mr speaker not all
meetings are engaging or go according to
plan and they remember vividly a meeting
with a foreign minister in this case a
foreign minister that demanded that the
meeting take place in english
the only problem being that that foreign
minister did not actually speak english
but had instructed his translators not
to intervene
several minutes in
with only the minister understanding
what had been said and parliamentary
colleagues becoming increasingly
frustrated i passed over a note saying
that this was getting ridiculous
david simply smiled in his usual way
about a minute later
so david went forward and said to the
minister
minister
your english is superb
where did you study
with tears rolling down colleagues
cheeks and they'll be able to make eye
contact for fear of damaging the
reputation of this house
but this was a perfect example of sir
david deploying his full sense of humor
and ability to address serious
situations and a polite and jovial tone
mr speaker just last week i and others
in his house had the privilege of
spending time with the david on the pal
adventure delegation he was leading
he was at his very best
ensuring that colleagues of all level
seniority were made to feel included and
that they played an active role
every day we conducted serious business
but he made sure we always found time to
laugh
it will come as no surprise
that even there he found time to demand
that south end he made a city
[Laughter]
this house has lost a great
representative
his family
a father and husband
i have lost a dear friend
but it was a real privilege to be on
with him on his final adventure thank
you mr speaker
thank you mr speaker i think if david
had been here to hear the word today he
would have loved the fact that there was
so much humor in the contributions from
people as well as the obvious warmth and
respect for his his decency i think you
know it's just so obvious how genuine
the tributes are
i knew him fairly well because of
working with him on animal welfare
issues and all i really want to do today
is to just quote um from some of the
animal welfare groups that have paid
tribute to him on social media world
animal protection talked about his
support for calls for an end to the
global wildlife trade the dog's trust
said that they were devastated to hear
of his death um
he was worked with him on support in the
end to the cruel puppy truck um puppy
smuggling trade um
the animal aid posted a picture of him
supporting a call for an end to the um a
ban on or calling for
a ban on game bird battery cages said
that they were shocked and sad and
described as a friend to animals
everywhere and i think i feel
particularly for the blue fox
campaigners which is the conservative
campaign against fox hunting and when
that was first established only a very
few um mps on the conservative benches
were supporters of that and so david was
so integral and he's got us to a place
now where it's really i think a bit of a
moot point whether there would ever be
um a successful attempt to overturn the
fox hunting ban and that's because we've
managed to win the debate on both sides
of the house rather than um just on this
side and he was just so much a part of
that um peter another animal welfare
campaign have said that they're going to
add a leaf with his name on it to their
tree of life memorial which celebrates
individuals who've made a difference and
they say that he did that in spades and
finally i just want to there was a
lovely tribute to him from nick palmer
who was an mp on the labor side in this
house and overlapped with him for quite
some time but he's now at compassion in
world farming and he wrote a lovely
article in the last few days and he said
he was especially struck by alistair
campbell's comment that the first thing
you noticed when david entered the room
was his beam and smile and that many of
us um
that not many of us are remembered in
politics are remembered especially for
our smiles and he can click which i
think is fair to say um but he concluded
um nick in this article he said when
animal sentience is officially on the
statute book when live exports end when
cages on farms are banished to history
all of us in the animal welfare movement
will celebrate and we should remember
the quiet idealism that made sir david
help bring it about wow
thank you mr speaker
in this debate the life of david amos
keeps invoking one word above all
kindness
and the family's heart-rending statement
reflected that word the archbishop of
york wrote that his life showed the true
meaning of kindness
and this would be the greatest of all
tributes to david if we or even just
some of us who are engaged in the daily
political battle may kindness our
resolution from this day forward there
is much reaching across the chamber in
this debate today but which of us in
this house can honestly say
when we have looked across the chamber
or those in our own parties that we have
never felt fallen prey to feelings of
contempt or lack of respect or
unkindness towards those who oppose us
which of us can honestly say we cannot
do better
kindness is giving without any
expectation of getting kindness inspires
hope and optimism which david also
embodied
like many on all sides we had our
disagreements but nobody could adopt
david's sincere wish to make the world a
better place with his kindness
and i wonder why the seven principles of
public life do not include the principle
of kindness and henceforth let kindness
be known as the david amis principle of
public life
he julia and the rest of his family
could be the nation
nothing more generous and we could do no
greater service to them and to david's
memory
than to learn to live this principle
more evidently in our daily political
lives
final contribution dr rupa
mr speaker the brutal killing of our
friends
david amos and i call him a friend i
know that we have an adversarial
workplace here we have a face-off don't
we but some of our best friends often
are on the other side aren't they i know
when i've been in a hole sometimes it's
people on that side who've sort of
helped me out and been friendly to me
it's all the more shocking to me and
painful because i'm probably the last
certainly the last labour mp who saw him
alive
and it was on that delegation to the
middle east last week
at the baggage reclaim as it happens
everyone else had scarpered everyone
else's stuff had gone mine i think i'd
missed because i've been tying up my
shoelaces or something he said no i'll
wait with you i was like come on you've
got to go to essex be off with you but
you know that was the measure of the man
how kind he was
and the next day when the last
stragglers were sort of saying we got
back it was a great trip thank you he
was the last whatsapp i saw
thanking everyone for their service
and how shocking that he was taken in
service a public servant in the line of
duty slain
at his surgery
i mean on on the trip again his million
dollar smile that we've heard so much
about won over everyone
one of these dignitaries i had to
introduce him to and i said you know
he's been a parliamentarian since the
last century but he never ages and
another one he said
in his inimitable way
oh do you know what i thought i had a
lot of kids because i've got five but
you've got 24.
and he's said to
he said to us in advance
on the coach ladies when we get there i
don't want any ruffling of his hair and
he's sitting on his lap any twiddling of
his tie because he's already got three
wives and he doesn't need any more
anyway look one could everyone's got so
many a mississippis and i was with him
for a week so i miss him dearly i was
shocked i could not process that news i
had to go and do my own in-person
surgery at the time when i got on the
panel of chairs he said you you should
be a shadow minister by now no comment
[Laughter]
he didn't want you know party profit and
nor do i in that case and so look when
our dear friend and it was so brilliant
to hear from kim who's a dear friend
already in a short space of time when
joe cox was taken from us we all said
that we should live by the
dicta of more in common i feel in life
we should be all a bit more like david
and that means being less
cross
and more cross party thank you
the question is that this service do not
adjourn as many of that opinion say aye
the eyes of it the eyes have it order
order we will now follow the sergeant
arms to process the saint margaret's
church for the service of remembrance
but can i say for mps and staff who wish
to watch the service at saint margaret's
it will be live on the annunciator
channel
505. yeah
thank you
hold on
now
um
pretty cute
okay
oh
[Music]
you